OBS freest immer so kurz, wenn ich auf stream klicke. Ganz wirr. So, und jetzt blinkt der
Browser auch hier. Perfekt, funktioniert. Weilong, tippistream, nightbot, streamlabs,
muss ja alles im Blick haben. Ich wurde ja gestern noch angerufen und sowas. Von der Telekom?
Jaja. Aber weil du sie geflammt hast auf Twitter. Ja. Die kümmern sich wirklich drum.
Der Twitter-Support sind glaube ich ganz arme Säcke. Die kriegen es immer direkt ab. Vor allem,
weil es noch übers Internet ist und da die Leute nochmal eine Nummer leichter flammen, weißt du?
Ja, aber ich habe bei sowas halt auch wenig Verständnis, sage ich ganz ehrlich. Ich meine,
sie haben einen Job. Sie sind dein Provider. Sie sollen halt ihren Job erfüllen. Das denke ich mir
auch. Ich meine, wenn ab und zu mal was ist, ist ja okay. Es kann immer mal einer ein bisschen kacke
werden. Ja, ich sage ja auch nichts.
Wenn mal, sagen wir mal, einmal im Monat oder so mal eine Störung da ist. Ja. Okay, aber dann
bitte auch beheben, ohne dass ich da irgendwie Stress schieben muss oder was. Ja, denke ich auch.
Ja, vor allem, es ist ja nicht so, als würden die es sich merken. Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass sie es tatsächlich teilweise nicht merken, aber es ist so, sie müssen es merken. Ich kann
mir das manchmal auch nicht vorstellen, wenn es dann heißt, wir wissen von nichts und bla bla bla,
wie bei dieser großen Störung geht das. Ja.
Also, eine Störung, die da im Juni oder so was war. Ja. Dann, ey, da ist der Tüter bei denen
förmlich eingerannt worden. Vielleicht wissen, vielleicht. Hast du geguckt so hier alle-störungen.de
oder wie die Seite da ist, oder... Vielleicht wissen sie absichtlich von nichts.
...über alle rote Ausschlagpunkte. Vielleicht haben sie sich gedacht, wir faken einfach, wir wissen
von nichts. Da gehen uns die Leute nicht so sehr auf den Sack. Weiß ja nie. So. Ich kriege
immer noch keine Viewer angezeigt. Wahrscheinlich ist Switch bei mir gerade kaputt. Aber es ist auch
kaputt da doch jetzt geht's schon jemand da weil bei mir ist im chat steht nichts
und der view account aktualisiert auch nicht schnell gucken
ich refreshe noch mal acht leute ich refreshe noch mal ich sehe nichts
jetzt sehe ich was der wagen 1 9 16 wollen bis am start ja ein wunderbar
jetzt funktioniert alles sehr schön ja aber nur minimieren also guck wenn ich
hier wenn ich im game bin ist nix und prezi und very fap möchtest du mit dem
namen irgendwas mitteilen
juli wie macht man das auch wenn er noch mal an steuerung shift n gut dann
dann
würde ich sagen gehe ich mal raus und hatte ich ein aber erst mal muss ich den
bot nano boosten ist noch richtig unter ihnen
weder und ihn gar nicht da macht nichts den bug musste blizzard melden er wird
sofort gefixt du weißt dass der bot nicht schießt ja winston fix hotfix
fixer runterfahren direkt fixen wir sonst ist das schlimm ist dass der
interessenfunk war halt schon dabei da
aber das ist das da werden dinger gefixt so was fand es in den letzten patch
notes junkers auf in chatzowschaft junkertown die goldkisten anschließen hat
performance einbrüche oder ich weiß nur wo ist das ausgekommen ist da liegt ja
immer so viel schrott auf dem tisch neuen bei einen oder zwei karten so gläser
Teller, Besteck und so. Ja, auf Hollywood
steht es am Anfang, ist auch viel Müll.
Ja, das ist ja nicht so
das Problem, aber bei Oasis, wo das rauskam,
konntest du mit Symmetra die Frames
von, keine Ahnung, auf 300
von 300 auf
sagen wir 30 reduzieren.
Echt? Ja, du hast mit Linkskrieg
den ganzen Scheiß aufgesammelt, der auf dem Tisch
gestanden ist und das hat so mega geruckelt.
Okay, nice.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
So, ich poste den Stream nochmal kurz auf
Twitter.
Ja, du kannst den ja mal kurz
ready machen oder was? Ja, ich lade
dich gleich ein.
So, habe ich irgendwie die blöden Overlays an dich
weg, weil du musst? Mal Vorschau gucken.
Nope. Ah, doch.
Win-Loss 13-13
ist nicht so ganz korrekt.
Dafür ist jetzt du fürs Wiederhalbweg
spielbar. Einige Boxen hast du zwar
immer noch, aber am Anfang. Ich habe die Patchnotes
gestern, wir haben sie uns jetzt zusammen angeguckt.
Diese ganzen Mini-Bugfixes
habe ich gar nicht so sehr gelesen.
Weiß gar nicht,
was alles bei Doomfist gefixt wurde.
Aber Doomfist war schon vorher nervig
genug.
Ich habe nur ein Video gesehen, das jetzt sowohl
Doomfist, ich glaube
ist das Doomfist Shift?
Weiß es nicht genau. Und der
Winston Jump,
dass die jetzt, wenn du sie
auf einer Treppe machst,
das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus in der
Practice Range, das probieren wir jetzt nochmal aus.
Also es ist jetzt wohl irgendwie so,
dass man jetzt
die Treppe hochslidet mit
dem Winston, anstatt
dass der Sprung ausgelöst
wird.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich auf die Treppe springe.
Nein.
Ihr seht meine krassen Winston-Jump-Skills.
Also sprich, wenn ich auf die Treppe springe.
What?
Ich glaube, ich muss weiter dahinter.
Gibt es eine größere Treppe?
Größere Treppe.
Ja.
Ja, man slidet die Treppe ein bisschen hoch.
Das ist jetzt wohl neu.
Früher war es so, dass es direkt an der Treppe aufgehört hat.
Aber ich habe nie wirklich viel mit der Treppe gesprochen.
Ich habe nicht viel mit dem Winston gespielt.
Deswegen kann ich da nicht so viel zu sagen.
Das hat sich wohl seit dem letzten Patch geändert.
Du siehst, du abkommst springen.
Hallo, Saboteur.
Wollen wir ihn mal inviten.
Das ist ja ein Fischerspiel.
Wow.
So, so.
Wird gestalkt.
Was hast du zur Zeit für ein Mikrofon?
Das, was am
MMX300 dran ist.
Bei Dynamics MMX300
das Mikrofon, was dabei ist.
Das ist meiner Ansicht nach,
das beste Headset-Mikrofon.
Über Headsets kann man sich ja an sich eh streiten,
ob sich das lohnt.
Preis-Leistungsmäßig bin ich der Ansicht,
lohnt sich das nicht.
Aber wenn man jetzt mal nicht rein nach Preis-Leistung geht,
sondern mal so ein bisschen Richtung Bequemlichkeit guckt
und von der Qualität her ist das
MMX300-Mikro wirklich ganz gut.
Es ist mir einfach, wenn ich hier am Spielen bin
und so ein bisschen rummoven am Schreibtisch,
ist mir es einfach lieber,
wenn ich da kein Mikro habe,
oder ein Mikro rumstehen habe.
Klingt echt ziemlich gut.
Hast du eine extra Soundkarte für?
Ja.
Top.
Audio-Interface, ein Motu-Track 16.
Bis der E-Ax da ist,
wenn es euch interessiert,
ich kann es euch mal kurz zeigen.
Ich zeige es euch mal kurz,
was ich an Audio-Hardware habe.
Screen-Capture, Display-Capture.
Ja.
Das da.
Genau, das Audio-Interface habe ich mir vor ein paar Jahren gekauft.
Das war eine der besten Entscheidungen,
sowas hier in der Richtung zu holen.
Du hast, mal gucken, ob die hier das Bild davon haben.
Genau.
Du hast hier jede Menge Anschlüsse dran.
Du hast hier so ein Breakout-Kabel dabei
mit massig XLR-Anschlüssen für Mikrofone,
für alle möglichen anderes Gedöns.
Hier vorne kannst du dann auch noch
nochmal,
zwei Kopfhörer anschließen
oder halt nochmal
zwei Kanäle Line-In.
Ist wirklich praktisch.
Und man kann hier halt über die Bedienelemente oben
alles einstellen.
Braucht man aber nicht,
denn
es ist auch eine coole Mixer-Software dabei.
Nämlich, ich hoffe, man sieht das hier irgendwo.
Ja, da, genau hier, da sieht man es.
Genau, so eine Mixer-Software ist dabei.
Mit der kann man, mit der kann man alles noch einstellen, was man will.
Also sprich, man kann dann auch
einstellen, wie das intern
routet, also sprich,
welcher Eingang zu welchem Ausgang
oder quasi, was wieder neu eingespeist wird
auf einer anderen Spur und sowas in der Richtung.
Ist richtig cool.
Da könnte man dann solche Sachen machen,
wie zum Beispiel, dass quasi ich im
Discord bin, jetzt mit dem Eax
und ich den Eax höre, allerdings
in meinem Hauptmix
dann das nicht dabei wäre.
Könnte man das machen.
BW.
So, fangen wir an.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Also, was ist aufwärmen?
Direkt, direkt ranken.
Display capture, remove.
Ready?
Ja, drückt auf.
Oh, wahrscheinlich kriegen wir jetzt gleich den Kami im Match.
Dann ist er ein Elo-Terrorist.
Bist du fertig oder was?
Hä? Weiß nicht.
Das wär's jetzt.
Ja, der ist rauchen.
Könnte passieren.
Gleich soll Kami still slappen.
Nein, sowas machen wir nicht.
Sowas machen wir nicht.
Hallo Hero LP.
Heute in der Schule mit dem Thema Videospiele gestartet.
Sowas macht man in der Schule mittlerweile.
Dazu erstmal 1-2 Seiten Text von Christian Pfeiffer.
Ach du Scheiße.
Was man sich...
Was man sich ja alles geben muss, ey.
TK möchte wissen, ob bei dir alles fit ist, Eax.
Ja.
Ja, natürlich.
Kennt ihr euch?
Er schreibt so, als würdet ihr euch schon irgendwie ewig kennen.
Na, alles fit, Chris?
Ist ja auch schon so eine Ewigkeit.
Schon zwei Jahre oder so.
Und damals zusammen Rainbow Six Siege.
Ah.
Ach so.
Da ging ja immer ab, der alte Spawn-Raper.
Das Spiel hat sich ja auch gut entwickelt.
Also, wenn am Anfang hast du ja gedacht, oh fuck, wieder so ein verkacktes Ubisoft-Spiel.
Aber mittlerweile sind sie ja schon im dritten Jahr, ne?
Zwei Jahre?
Drei Jahre?
Und versorgen das immer noch.
Also für Ubisoft-Verhältnisse hatte ich das gemacht.
Wie das rankt da ist und so.
Ganz ehrlich, keine Ahnung.
Weißt du das?
Wie sich das mittlerweile spielt?
Es ist vor allem in Ordnung.
Das Problem, also das, was mich am Ende weggetrieben hat, war eigentlich bloß der Netgoat.
Weil die Leute sind um die Ecke gepickt und du hast die, keine Ahnung, gefühlten Jahrzehnte
zu spät gesehen, ne?
Also, ich hab noch kein Spiel erlebt, was so komische Killcams hat.
Wie Rainbow Six.
Also, sprich die Killcams, die sich überhaupt nicht mit der Realität gedeckt haben.
In der Killcam hat der Typ quasi so das Twitch-Aim des Todes gehabt, so.
Da hatte ich quasi Flick, Flick, Flick, tot.
Moment.
So war das in echt aber nicht jetzt.
Aber in der Killcam sah es halt so aus.
Oh, Mastergame hier.
Mastergame.
Defend.
Oh, warte mal.
Da haben wir schon einen Kree.
Ich kann einen Junk reinpicken.
Hast du ein paar Tipps für Ranked?
Ähm.
Spielen.
Das ist halt nicht so.
Das ist, hat man jetzt ja über die letzten paar Streams bei mir auch gesehen.
Als ich wieder angefangen hab jetzt seit Season 3, äh, Season 3, war ich mega scheiße.
Ich bin jetzt zwar immer noch nicht sonderlich gut, aber schon deutlich besser als, äh,
im ersten Stream.
Ist einfach, einfach Übungssache.
Und nichtsdestotrotz, was letztendlich natürlich richtig was gebracht hat, sind meine huge
Mercy Plays.
Verstehen, dass wir jetzt hier mal von denen...
Ha, guck, er hat Mercy geswitcht.
Nice.
Perfekt.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, warum er Sombra in der Defend spielen will, aber, naja.
Hat, ähm, hat Dallas Fuel, haben das auf...
Was, weiß ich nicht, was war das für eine Map?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was das für eine Map war.
Ähm, könnte es Hanamura sogar gewesen sein.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, irgendeine Map.
Haben die, hat, äh, einer der Supporter, die haben Single Support gespielt, aber mit,
mit Sombra.
Ging halt übelst ab, der Typ.
Hatte, hatte gefühlt jeden, jeden Fight EMP.
Ja, das geht halt schon, aber dann brauchst du halt...
Ha, mal gucken, mal gucken, ob ich jetzt das Timing drauf hab.
Mit dem Shatter.
Ich mach's mal, ich mach's mal zwei Sekunden.
Nein.
Aber das hätte getroffen.
Hätten Gegner da gestanden.
Haben die Symmetra?
Ja, ja, ja, haben sie.
Oh, Pharah oben.
Ich hab nur noch, noch 700 Schild.
Schild weg.
Wo ist, wo ist der Gengu?
Der, der Reinhardt ist fast tot vorne im, im Chalk.
Der Symmetra ist hinten.
Mercy und Pharah sind auch, sind vorne.
Oh, ich bin gecharged.
Shit.
Oben, oben.
D.Va ist hochgeflogen.
Hinten ist noch die Symmetra.
Ich bleib mal auf dem Punkt stehen.
70%.
Moment, wir sind, die sind total overextended.
Fuck.
Was machen die denn da vorne?
Schrank, äh, Reihensitz.
Ich hab, äh, 9% bis Shatter.
7.
Hammerklei.
Oh, jetzt wird sie gedeift, die Sombra.
Ich glaub, die gehen hinten rum.
Ja, ja, sieht, sieht, sieht's, sieht sehr danach aus.
Pharah kommt vorne rum.
Ich bleib mal auf dem Punkt.
Ja, bin da.
Genji low.
Nee, die Pharah ist zu unserem Spawn hinter.
Ist weg.
Nice.
Ach so.
Boah, erst mal einspielen, ey.
Ey, ich bin, ich hab übelst kalte Hände, ey.
Ich kann kaum moven.
Irgendwie.
Irgendwo wird was gegrillt.
Äh, hinten rechts muss noch ne, muss noch ne, ne Symmetra sein.
Mhm.
Ich hab Shatter am Start.
Okay, die gehen durch, die gehen wieder durch.
Äh, ich hab D.Va auf dem Punkt bei mir.
Wisst ihr, ist der Reinhardt nicht gestorben?
What the fuck?
Ich geh wechseln.
Pfuh.
Ich bleib mal Reinhardt.
Schild brauchen wir immer.
Keine Ahnung, der Reinhardt ist einfach nicht gestorben.
Kein Schild oben, nix.
Ich hab übelst kalte Hände, ey.
Schrecklich.
Mercy ist oben.
Oben drauf.
Ja, mit Pharah.
Wir sollten da gleich mal contesten, wenn sie da vorne durchkommen.
Genji ist low.
Der rechts Reinhardt.
Der hat keinen Heal, der Reinhardt.
Warte, wir haben immer noch die Pharah über uns.
Ich bin fast, ich hab, bin, bin low.
Okay, nice.
Jetzt können wir ran.
Jetzt contesten wir den Scheiß.
Genji down.
Oh, das war jetzt Overkill.
Das war Overkill.
Das war ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Vor allem noch die EMP dabei.
Hammer time.
Ey.
Dass du mich verarschen, Reinhardt.
Ich war aus dem Weg.
Der Gengu ist wieder da.
Und er wurde gackt.
Ich spiel grad voll den Scheiß zusammen.
Ich hab so kalte Hände, ey.
Ich treff nix.
Aber das muss man mit Reinhardt glücklicherweise nicht.
Also normalerweise spiel ich ja auch immer so zum Aufwärmen.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Wenn Sire Reinhardt.
Ah, nice.
Nice work.
Der wird gebasht.
Damn.
Wo, wo, wo grillt die Sombra?
Linke Seite.
Hinter dir.
Irgendwo muss die gewesen sein.
Ist da.
Ne, ne, die ist noch da.
Ich hör's hier grillen.
Ich bin am.
Ah.
Er ist voll in den Hammer reingerannt.
Mercy und Pharah sind oben.
Mercy down.
Ich bin am.
Ein HP.
Shield gen.
Ich hab gleich Shatter wieder.
Sechs Prozent.
Die liegen.
Ja Doomfist, fick dich.
Aber vielleicht kriegen wir nen Rats.
Wird echt sehr, sehr, sehr nice.
Eine Resurrection zu bekommen.
Huge Rats.
Okay, ne, ne.
Ich geh zurück.
WTF.
Hilf.
oder so, damit es schneller geht.
Ach, knapp.
Symmetra ist linke Seite.
Lasert, lasert vor sich hin.
Doomfist!
Fick dich, Drecksschaf!
Jutsch!
WTF?
So, passen.
Boah!
Moment, wo sind auf einmal alle hin?
Unsere Mercy ist gestorben.
Ach, scheiße.
Da war ich zu sehr am
hämmern. Das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Das gibt's doch nicht, ey.
Wir...
Overtime! Overtime!
War das nur ein Overtime-Push?
Nein. Das war aber
am zweiten Punkt war es halt von Anfang bis Ende
Overtime.
Naja, stimmt.
Die Saga hat gerade die Grav über die halbe Map
geschossen.
Da muss die Mercy einfach
ein bisschen mehr Abstand halten zu den DPS-Max-Range-Halber.
Ich habe so vorhin nicht gecheckt. Auf einmal
alle weg. Hä? Hallo?
Drei Gegner tot?
Reingehämmert?
Da habe ich noch null das Gefühl für...
Ja, im Prinzip sind ja eigentlich nur zwei Leute
gestorben. Also ich und die Mercy.
Aber das hat ja schon... Das reicht ja schon.
Wenn Mercys sterben, aktuell ist es vorbei.
Ist ein bisschen ärgerlich.
Aber egal.
Erstmal aufhören.
Ja.
Selbst wenn wir jetzt
nicht unbedingt wieder alles gewinnen, ist ganz gut.
Kann man sich umso besser einspielen noch.
Genau.
Welches Mikrofon benutzt du im Moment?
Fragen mich heute so viele Leute.
Klingt das irgendwie besonders?
Habe ich irgendwie super Settings heute an?
Ich habe das
Spire Dynamics MMX300 Headset
und das ist das ganz normale Mikrofon,
was dabei ist. Ist aber von
den Headsets eines der besten Mikros.
Und an einem gescheiten Audio-Interface
und nicht an einer verrauschten
Onboard-Soundkarte.
Ich fühle mich so abgewertet.
Ja, das Blue Yeti ist auch nice.
Firestrike.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ocarino.
Gleich, gleich, gleich.
U-Chuck, U-Chuck gibt es gleich.
Nicht U-Chuck.
Weiter.
Die D.Va ist sicher im Auto drin.
So, so.
Oh, war das knapp.
Ich push den, ich push den Soldier.
Der ist fast down, der Soldier.
Der hat nicht mehr viel.
Mercy heilt ihn, ich kriege ihn nicht tot.
Der ist geflankt ins Café.
Ja, passt.
Heißt das Ding überhaupt Café?
Overwatch-Callouts, lull.
Schild schreddern.
Macht er jetzt flank-hard?
Soldier ist oben.
Oh.
Ich pushe weiter, da kann ich nicht treffen.
Soldier ist unten.
Oh, nice dann.
Mercy habe ich raus.
Das war zu viel.
Die haben aber sau viele Olds geused.
Die haben da zu.
Die haben da alles an ihren Olds rausgehauen.
Ja, jetzt haben wir auch ne Mercy.
Nice.
Merkli.
Ah, fuck.
Ja, der rein hat Shatter, oder?
Chum.
Ne, ne, der ist raus, der Shatter.
Den hat der Freund benutzt.
Die Night.
So, jetzt noch die Dings von die D.Va.
Ah, die ist oben.
Flankhawk, Flankhawk.
Nein, Genji, NHP.
Alter, diese...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ist der Hook nicht mehr killt?
Nein.
Fuck.
Weggecharged.
Ähm.
RIP.
Du kriegst den Soldier ums Verrecken nicht tot, wenn er im Heelfeld steht mit ner Mercy drauf.
Kannst du vergessen, wenn du nicht one-shottest.
Oh, Mercy, Mercy, Mercy.
Komm her.
Oh!
Nice.
Merkki down.
Wir können pushen.
Volle Kanne, volle Kanne, Jungs.
Volle Pole rein.
Wo sind sie denn alle?
Da ist was drin.
Da ist die Mercy wieder da.
Ah, das...
Kriegt den Genji nicht.
Die Va- Die war flankt von hinten.
Die Mercy ist wieder da.
Wo sind da alle...
Fuck.
Wo sind dann alle jetzt gerade gewesen?
Der Fight ging hier gefühlte drei Minuten am Kart.
Ich hatte drei Minuten der Genji zu tun.
WTF?
Was war das denn jetzt gerade?
Und Yaroslav R Philip applaudiert.
Okay, ich warte mal.
Ich glaube wir brauchen einfach eine Frontline.
Oder eine Sire-Ulti wäre auch noch nicht schlecht.
Ja, also gefühlt geht da richtig viel rein gerade.
Alter, das gibt es nicht! Ich war um die Ecke, fuck!
Du musst den dicken Bauch von Roadhog einberechnen.
Eindeutig, ey!
Ist doch das ein Roadhog-Problem?
First-World-Roadhog-Probleme.
Oh, nice!
Gott sei Dank, ey.
Dein Bauch hat rausgeguckt, haha! Ja, das stimmt!
Wie in echt, lul!
Hook üben wir nochmal.
McCree oben links.
Mann!
So ein nicer Hook.
Ich komme jetzt mal was mit ein bisschen mehr Speed nach vorne.
Oh Mann.
Hallo xxhans.
Ich hau mal ab.
Wir können nochmal regroupen.
Okay.
Schwierig.
Ich glaube auch der Hamza schießt gar nicht aufs Schild, wenn er nichts zu tun hat.
Ich flieg gleich ran.
Mercy ist fast tot.
Linke Seite.
Ich hab die Mercy.
Mercy ist weg.
Don't C9.
Don't C9, please.
Jawoll.
Jetzt haben wir beiden Overtime drüber gepusht.
Was eine Runde, ey.
Ich bin null warm.
Ohne Witz.
Ich hab immer noch übelst kalte Hände.
Aber es ist die erste Runde.
Steht nicht umsonst Aufwärmen dran.
Ich spiel Defense Spiel.
Ich spiel wieder Reinhardt.
Wir brauchen ein Schild hier.
Irgendjemand hat im Chat gerade was zu CPU oder sowas gefragt.
Warte mal.
Ähm.
Hältst du Leute...
Was?
Hältst du heute einen i7-3770 noch für ausreichend?
Also normale Gamer.
Also nicht streamen und so weiter.
Ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht, was der für Kerne, Taktraten und was das für eine Generation
ist.
So weit bin ich da bei der Intel-Benahmung nicht drinne.
Aber 3770 klingt zu der damaligen Zeit eigentlich nach einem der besseren.
Also CPU-Leistung hat sich eh nicht so viel getan die letzten Jahre.
Das wird bestimmt reichen.
Kommt drauf an, was du spielen willst und vor allem was du noch für eine Grafikkarte
hast.
Grafikkarte ist prinzipiell natürlich wichtiger.
Tendenziell.
Kommt aufs Spiel immer letztendlich an.
So.
Jetzt Firestriken wir nochmal.
Ha!
Ich hab was getroffen.
Und?
Gab's das?
14%.
Yeah!
Zwei Stück.
Die haben Genji.
Genji und Tracer.
Tracer sieht aus als flankt sie rechts rum.
Die haben keinen richtigen Tank.
Ich glaub die gehen rechts rum.
Tracer ist oben auf dem Dach.
Ich hab das Gefühl die gehen rechts rum.
Die sind auf dem Dach rum.
Die D.Va ist rechts.
Tracer ist vorne.
Anna hat sich selber gekillt.
Haben Genji deflect.
Mercy, Mercy.
Die D.Va hat sich selber gekillt.
Die D.Va raus aus dem Mech.
Help, help, help, help.
Bist alleine.
WTF?
Besser.
Moment.
Hätten wir nicht auch nochmal ne Chance kriegen sollen?
Hä?
Wir hatten doch nur 14 Sekunden, hallo?
Was ist das?
Das ist definitiv nicht richtig.
Hä?
Da stimmt was nicht.
Komisch.
Definitiv.
Ja.
Du kriegst, kriegt man nicht.
Die sind unter einer Minute und wir mit Overtime.
Normalerweise.
Doch ziemlich sicher.
Ja, normalerweise kriegst du nochmal nen Push.
Du kriegst, du kriegst nen Push.
Also, ich glaube, das Einzige ist, wenn du mit Overtime ins Ziel kommst und die Gegner über ne Minute haben, ist glaub ich anders.
Könnte zumindest sein, aber unter ner Minute.
Ja, dann, ja.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das, das, normalerweise hätt's da nen Push gegeben.
Oder vielleicht, weil das Hybrid spielt.
Was?
Nee.
Keine Ahnung.
Was auch immer.
Aber da siehst du mal, im Prinzip haben die Gegner sogar mehr Zeit gehabt als wir und wir sind in Overtime ins Ziel gekommen.
Weil die haben den kompletten zweiten Punkt mit Overtime gepusht.
Direkt nächstes Game.
Ah, ich hab auch noch voll kalte Finger.
Kein, keine Master Games mehr.
Vieles Batman.
Oh, wir haben den Genji Smurf drinne.
Speed.
Max Lull.
Wer ist das?
Hype noch.
Wer auch immer du bist.
Bist du im Chat?
Big Fan.
Nice.
Hyper Lull.
Ich probier's mal.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Hm.
Ja, der Genji Smurf wird uns schon carryen.
Ja.
Was hältst du denn von Reinhardt auf dem Punkt?
Ja, was soll ich davon halten?
Ne, würdest du spielen, wenn du dir's aussuchen dürftest.
So war das gemeint.
Ja.
Ist sonst noch einsmutig, wenn du hier Halloween durch dürftest.
So war das gemeint.
Also, wenn du jetzt hier Con- ... ... Hoheit hättest hier.
S styles.
Ich bin daорд skeptisch.
Oh.
Haben wir ne Mercy?
Ach.
Die ist tot.
Oh.
T- preached.
Echt jetzt?
Wir verlieren das?
Ja, sie waren alle tot.
Verrückter Genji-Main und ich auf den Punkt.
Üü- Merc.
Ich versuch mal zu dir hochzukommen, dich zu heilen.
Da kommt natürlich gerade ein Harambe.
Uuuh.
Ich weiß zwar nicht genau, wo du bist.
Ich stehe hier mit Heal vor unserem Ausgang.
Bissig.
Genji low.
Junk low.
Ich muss mal hier ein bisschen rumcrinen oben.
Die machen mir ein bisschen viel Damage.
Die haben überhaupt keinen richtigen Heal, die Gegner.
Kriegen wir das jetzt sogar?
Ich bin mir da noch nicht so ganz sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Fuck.
Dacht ihr, wenn wir für den Genji main ulten, dann geht das schon.
Und ich bin drin.
Da geht nix.
Ich warte mal auf dich.
Nein!
Das ist es dann.
Weg du, you know.
So, das müssen wir jetzt aber zumindest einmal kriegen.
Also FPS-technisch ist schon wieder total scheiße bei mir.
Was machen die denn da vorne?
Warum lassen die sich jetzt alle recken?
Ich kann da nicht mal snipern da hinten.
Es geht mir...
Ich bin verloren.
WTF?
Der Aufer-Externe.
Der Attent des Todes war das gerade.
Geil, können wir immer noch gewinnen.
Das habe ich schon gedacht, ne?
Komm, easy win die ersten zwei Games.
Schreibst du beim Master Plus in den Stream-Titel, aber fail.
Was ist denn mit dem Genji eigentlich los?
In der letzten Runde ging der voll ab und jetzt auf einmal ist er auf.
Jin Muffin?
Ja.
Oh, jetzt natürlich bester.
Jetzt muss ich mal eine huge Mercy-Place machen.
Weil da keine Mercy mehr spielen will.
Huge Mercy-Place.
Wir machen unsere bewährte Taktik, würde ich sagen, oder?
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob die so funktioniert, weil ich noch nicht warm bin.
Easy.
Ich muss mal unten heilen ein bisschen.
Sag, wenn du Heal brauchst.
Was?
What the fuck, ey?
Was war das denn?
Dich hat irgendwas one-shotted gerade gefühlt.
Der Junctwit.
So ein geiler Jar, besser.
Weiß nicht, wie sie auf die Idee gekommen sind, dass der auch noch sich selbst kein Damage nehmen muss von mir.
Nicht das Problem.
Er kann ganz abwärts.
Nichts geschehen.
Ein bisschen Dach.
Could be in position, so wie bei einer Schachtel.
Sag mal, wo...
Ich muss gut dran.
Bitte nicht in den Kasten ziehen.
Hm.
Damit mir schön ein Gegner ins Gesicht springen kann.
Links ist Winst mit Mercy dran.
Ich muss weg.
Puh!
Boom.
Noch mehr Boom.
Huge Mercy-Place.
Hab gleich Ulti hier.
Oh, ich muss weg.
Ich verpiss mich.
Gib mir mal kurz. Ach nee, bist ja kein Lucio mehr.
Huge Mercy Plays machen.
Leute, Leute, Achtung. Oh oh, ich muss weg.
Ich switch mal wieder auf Lucio.
Ich bin eh nicht kurz vor Ult und wir sind gleich durch.
Ich muss schnell wieder zurück.
Nice.
No aim, no pray in Winston, man. So einfach ist es nicht.
Winston gut zu spielen finde ich gar nicht so einfach.
Jetzt springst du in eine D.Va rein, du wirst in einer Sekunde gebrutzelt.
D.Va, nicht zu vergessen, plus Junkrat.
Ich hab vorhin bei Akami gesehen, da springt er mit Winston durch den Gage und springt hoch.
Springt dann drei Leute rein.
Ey, dann hat es in einer Millisekunde so aus dem Bild getreten.
Ich hab letztens auch exklusiv geguckt, irgendeine Codmap war das.
Auch Primal Rage gezogen, pff.
So instant geplatzt.
1000 TP, einfach instant geplatzt.
Ich bin weg.
Der Rod, oh fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Warum bin ich da jetzt reingesprungen?
Warum bin ich da reingesprungen?
Warum, warum?
Ohhhh.
Ich kann Mercy nicht.
So kacke.
Super Junk.
Super Mercy Place.
Ich würde gerne jemanden anfliegen.
Meine Schüsse gehen durch?
Die gehen einfach durch?
Und die Fahrer, die sind wirklich geil auf mich.
Was ist das?
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
Oh, ich muss weg.
Genji, ich seh dich da oben nicht.
Junkrat.
Oh oh.
Rekt.
Gehen wir switchen.
Weiß nicht, ob mein Cree auch gerade ganz gut ist, aber eventuell geht er noch näher.
Oh D.Va.
Was geht?
Ich kann der D.Va nicht hinterher fliegen, das funktioniert nicht.
Du bist schon instant drin.
Okay, wenn wir die jetzt weit vorne halten, haben wir die Runde.
Also die müssen ohne Moira kämpfen.
Winston low.
Junkrat links.
Geil.
Geglitcht.
Hast du keinen Rest?
Ich kann nicht.
Ich hab 30.000 Gefühle Gegner am Arsch.
Speed.
Ich mach Speed.
Sonst kommen wir nicht mehr rechtzeitig hin.
Oh nein.
RIP.
Also ich komm nochmal drauf, aber doch nicht.
Ne, wir sind alle down.
Ich versteh auch nicht so ganz, warum wir den letzten Fight verloren haben.
Moin Orton und FSK 1996.
Auto-Aim-Dreckshelden, ey.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Puh.
Scheiße, ey.
Ist doch nett.
Ei, ei, ei.
Next.
Warte mal kurz.
Oh fuck.
Kannst du kurz mit dem Chat labern oder so?
Bisschen.
Habt ihr gehört?
Ich soll mit dem Chat labern.
Mercy-Main wieder am Start.
Ja, ich...
persönlich anna bei den supports mit am meisten spaß und da hat man auch immer das gefühl man
kann was machen mit mercy kannst ja im endeffekt nichts machen aus ein bisschen rumfliegen und
halt heilen und damage boosten ja mit anna ich bin gestern auf hannah moore komplettes gegnerteam
läuft an mir vorbei ich bin halt mercy und ich denke mir so hmm sleep dart gibt halt nicht ich
will wieder halbwegs warme hände kriegen jetzt hast du eine mechanische tastatur nee aber meine
tastatur gibt zu langsam aber sicher den geist auf ich muss mit dem nächsten neue kaufen und
dann wahrscheinlich eine mechanische ich weiß aber noch nicht welche genau kriegt ja keine
normal es gibt ja kaum normale in anführungsstrichen tastaturen mehr wenn du die
irgendeine mechanische holst dann ist das meistens so ein super krasses sonstwas gaming keyboard mit
rgb und 50 millionen makro tasten und sonst was ja sie haben uns da sicher mercy ist
das op was zurzeit gibt gefolgt von weiß nicht junkrat du hast na ja du kannst das schon anna
geht schon aber mercy ist halt quasi wenn du in teamfights hast leute sterben und du kannst
retten ist quasi mercy so was wie zwei bis drei helden zusätzlich aber trotzdem spiele ich mercy
nicht gerne und kann auch mercy nicht gescheit spielen
aber bleibt dann manchmal nichts anderes übrig junkrat ist übertrieben zurzeit moin rick ich
muss mal gucken wenn es dann soweit ist also wenn die tastatur hier wirklich den geist aufgibt was
es dann wird es wird definitiv nicht dieses übertriebene 300 euro asus gaming keyboard
es gibt von asus irgendwie so ein asus rock claymore sonstwas kostet 300 euro oder noch mehr
wo ich frage wofür ich meine das ist eine tastatur natürlich mit rgb beleuchtung weil mit rgb beleuchtung
ist alles besser so haste enthiltet sagen wir nicht suchen kann ich habe mich ja gemutet war ich die
ganze zeit gemutet kann das sein keine ahnung disco ich war ja eh nicht da aber davor hast du
mich gehört nicht dass die letzte runde irgendwie gemutet war die ganze zeit bin ich da gut wunderbar
ja warte mal ich jemand andere internet jerry tastatur für 70 euro ist nicht welche denn
patschi m9 hast du da irgendwie einen guten tipp ansonsten war ich das wie wie immer ich lese halt
ein paar test oder gucken was da so am besten ist so spiel starten und dann so schnell hast
du geswitcht ich muss aus den adapter einschalten
mit dem kindes ja heilig wendt ein netzwerk adapter option oder was das da ist eine soft
sophisticated ach ja du hast du immer das setup von dir geschickt mit mit den zwei netzwerkkarten
genau ich suche keine ahnung die fahrer stand gerade still so ich schieße dreimal auf ging
durch so lange muss ich sagen jetzt wenn ich so anhand an greife oben ist er immer noch kaltmüllereck
sau, aber unten ist schon warm.
Es geht aufwärts. Ich cue, ne?
Unten ist schon warm. Was willst du damit sagen?
Die Hand!
Die Hand. Kappa Pride. Die Hand.
Ja, zum Hände aufwärmen
gibt's ja so ein paar Tricks, ne?
Was gibt's da?
Erzähl mal.
Special Tricks.
Außer diese Tricks.
Gibt's da irgendwie so Programmer-Tipps?
Also, eigentlich am sinnvollsten
oder das, was viele machen,
ist ja immer Händewaschen, aber das bringt ja nix.
Das ist immer so kurzzeitig.
Aber
die beste Lösung ist halt, du machst, was weiß ich,
ein, zwei Liegestütze. Das reicht schon.
Boah, Sport.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Und du machst für die Pros solche
Wärmepads. Handwärmer, ja.
Ja.
Aber da lege ich nix von.
Ich finde das lustig, wenn du teilweise
die Streams siehst. Oh, wir haben ein Match.
Wenn du die Streams teilweise siehst,
wenn sie zwischen den Runden alle dann
an ihren Päckchen so am Reiben sind.
Ich probier's nochmal mit Speed.
Mir geht's... Oh, nein.
Nein.
Ich muss Mercy... Leute, warum muss ich
immer Mercy spielen?
Das geht mir so...
Richtung Dangelmund wieder abgerutscht, deswegen gibt's keine Mercy mehr.
Was ist das jetzt?
Okay.
Okay, Moment.
Was machen wir da jetzt?
Probier's mal.
Was nennt man hier Sanktum?
Sanktum ist das mit dem Loch?
Jep.
Innen drinne.
Ja, ja, in der Mitte.
Wir könnten...
Wenn wir einen Shankred hätten,
könnten wir rechte Side-Battle machen.
Ansonsten wird gehuckt.
Ich hab zwar meine Zweifel,
dass ich überhaupt jemals Heilung sehen werde, aber...
Ja, Lucio, Moira als Auf...
Auf...
Auf Fahrer, nein, wirst du nicht.
Der soll nicht groß heilen.
Der Lucio ist bestimmt am Speedboost,
der geht hinterher rennen.
Spiel mal den Zwerg.
Der kommt ja schon viel zu spät aus dem Spawnhaus.
Den Zwerg können wir hier nicht spielen jetzt.
Komm, alle rechts.
Ich versuch, das Schild kaputt zu machen.
Ich lass mich doch hier nicht runterziehen.
Orisa.
Die Bett...
Ich geh in die Mitte.
Richtung Punkt.
Wir sind im Hallo, aber richtig.
Orisa ist auf dem Punkt.
Ich geh ran.
Was?
Warum hat das nicht getroffen?
Es ist eine Saria unten drinne.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Mercy ist links geflogen.
Weiß nicht, ob die flanken wollen.
Nee, ich seh den Strahl noch.
Und Hanzo am Start.
Hanzo.
Gucken, dass da nix von rechts flenkt.
Ah, komm, ey.
Keiner reingelaufen, fuck.
Ist das mein echter Account?
Das ist quasi mein echter Account.
Ich hab mir extra einen neuen Account erstellt,
weil ich seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt hab.
Einfach das wegkicken.
Leute.
Hier holen wir uns.
Ich hab mit einer Rakete...
Äh, ich brauch...
Ich glaub, wir sind halt instant gestorben.
Wir gehen jetzt in die Mitte rein.
Hanzo!
Wir müssen jetzt durch.
Mercy ist down.
Nice.
Oh!
Was ging mit dem Genji ab?
Der Genji hat euch ganz schön, äh, ne?
Gerade.
Mir egal.
Ja, und KS.
Ich geh mal...
Na, wobei, ich brauch sehr viel.
Vieles Pablo, man.
Viel, ja.
Da hat einer...
Da hat einer einen Spiegel geguckt.
Der ist heute ein scheiß Tag zum Zocken.
Geht nix rein.
Wir müssen's ja auch nicht übertreiben.
Wenn's gar nicht funktioniert, dann lassen wir's.
Nee, das ist so dieses klassische, äh, überzockt-Gefühl.
Gestern haben wir's ja auch übertrieben.
Sie haben's total übertrieben.
Das ist das Problem, wenn man kein...
Wenn man nur Off-Dings hat, so.
Dann geht keiner mehr rein, ne?
Ich hab mal geswitcht.
So ein Draw Talk, das hat man wirklich nie getragen.
Zen ist tot.
Ich bin down.
Wir haben keinen gescheiten Support, das sagt Moira Lucio, ist ein Dreckscombo.
Das ist nix, was man ordentlich heilen kann.
Mister Santa, das, äh, weißt du was, das war ich, das war ein Zeug.
Ich hab's nur, das ist nur eine Schuhe.
Nicht so ein D-J.
Ich hab nur einen D-J, der...
Ich hab nur einen D-J.
Und der hat immer noch so viel G.
Bla, bla, bla.
War ursprünglich so ein Undercover-Account.
Heal.
Ja, die resten, wir verlieren halt den Kampf.
Es ist scheiße, das sackt richtig.
Mit Lucius Moira, was ist das?
Die haben auch überhaupt keinen Heal oder sonst was.
Äh, was war denn das gerade?
Was zum Teufel war das gerade?
Lagge ich oder was?
Ich hatte gerade...
Ich bin gerade mit D.Va vom Spawn bis zum Torbogen geflogen.
Oder war das Anzeige-Bug?
Vielleicht switcht einer bei denen, wenn ich mal so tue, als spiele ich Mercy.
Ja, der Lucius hat geswitcht.
Jetzt bin ich Solo-Support.
Ja, das ist Solo-Support.
Okay, okay.
Jetzt haben wir wieder kein Speed.
It's bad.
Wie cool, wir sind sowas von cool.
Ich kann nicht rausgescheitert.
Rekt.
Gegen den Genji habe ich keinen Spaß, das weiß ich jetzt schon.
Wenn der Ding steckt, der Hawk wenigstens mal die Bubble kaputt machen würde, dann hätte ich echt einen einfachen Tag.
Gibt's nicht.
Ich hasse das.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich sag dir, ich kann wirklich so Teammates nicht ausstehen, die die Schilde nicht kaputt machen.
Du stehst als TPS, da musst du das Solo machen und hast keinen Impact.
Mach den Gengu tot.
Oh, nicht so extrem rein, Leute.
Doch, ab geht's.
In your face.
Das ging gut.
Sehr, sehr nice.
Oh, der Affe will's wissen.
Das sind so'n Reaper.
Rechts ist ne Moira.
Au.
Ich mach mal Damage Boost auf dir. Sag mal, was passiert.
Ich seh Main nicht.
Sollten wir eigentlich packen.
Nice.
Kaum haben wir OP-Held am Start. Easy.
W.T.F.
Dein Reaper.
Ernsthaft.
Dein fucking Reaper.
Wonka S.
Ey, der Reaper-Kill, ey. So fail.
Gibt's nicht.
Ich hab gewonnen.
Willst du gucken oder kann ich rausziehen?
Kannst rausziehen.
Wie viel fehlt auf Master?
40 oder so? 50?
Äh, 65?
Bist du auch wieder drunter getroppt?
Durch unsere ersten zwei krassen Mega-Games?
Ich queue weiter.
14 fehlen wieder.
Aber gestern war auch so'n übertrieben krasser Tag.
Also, ging ab.
Warum machen wir mal Aufwärmen weg?
Wir sind jetzt aufgewärmt.
Ist schon der Wahnsinn, ey.
Was Mercy für'n Impact aufs Game hat.
Und dann heißt's ja nur, oh, wir wollen ja nicht,
dass sie so viel Impact aufs Game hat.
Vor allem die Änderung, ne?
Die Änderung war, ja,
es macht ja nicht so viel Spaß zu spielen
und bla und hier und sonst was.
Und jetzt machen wir's einfach OP as fuck.
Und dann patchen wir sie.
Und jetzt ist sie immer noch OP as fuck.
So, perfekt.
Ja, genauso muss ein Rework aussehen.
Genau.
Ich mein, eigentlich hätte man sich das
von Anfang an überlegen können.
Außerdem, wenn man ein paar Pros gefragt hätte.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
das Feedback wär da gewesen,
dass das quasi Must-Have ist.
Allein schon, dass du halt deinen Push am Laufen halten kannst.
Teamfight, zwei Sterne auf beiden Seiten.
Kannst retzen. Wer gewinnt den Fight wohl?
Mhm.
Ich glaub, ich, ich muss,
nein, ich pick mal, ich pick mal irgendeinen Tank jetzt.
In der Hoffnung, ich muss nicht.
Was spielt ein Viking Pazoo?
Paz-Paz-Panzer
AU ist Mercy Main.
Das ist gut.
Panzer.
Jetzt haben wir ne
perfekte Comp.
Mit, ah, nice, nice, nice.
Aber Viking
will wahrscheinlich Moira spielen, wie's aussieht.
Was mach ich denn, äh, D.Va-Solo-Tank ist kacke.
Soll ich, ich könnte,
ich könnte Winston spielen für die Tankstelle.
Oder, aber komm, nein,
wir spielen, wir spielen, wir spielen
klassisch mit, mit Hammer.
Bin ich auch ein Fan von.
Es ist diese Season hier,
wo wir jetzt, beziehungsweise hier mit dem Account,
wo wir grad spielen, ich glaube, ich musste noch
nie so oft
und am Stück
Helden spielen, die ich nicht spielen wollte.
Junkrat Trap
oder so, hm hm, nope.
Scatter.
So, direkt.
Hat grad den Header des Todes
nicht umgefallen.
Echt jetzt? Der springt mit uns rein?
Der will gefistet werden von mir.
Schild fast down
von Reinhard.
Den holen wir jetzt, den holen wir jetzt.
Nein, alter.
Mach ihn platt.
Nein. Ich wollte, ich muss, muss
zum Heal.
Pass auf, pass auf, Hanzo.
Ich bin hier nur am Fernbehammer drücken.
So viele Schilde. Hanzo fast tot.
Oh, oh.
Charm Winston.
Oh, Spring ist lieb.
Hilfe, Hilfe, Hilfe. Leute, Leute, Leute.
Der ist weg.
Warte, da stehen aber noch alle hinten. Achtung.
Akateki Wukarao.
MonkaS. Das war ein richtiger
MonkaS.
Ist der wieder da?
Wat? Oh Gott, ey.
Ich flank jetzt da nicht
mit dir. Guck mal, ob ich da
retten kann. Pass, pass auf. Also die Tracer
geht jetzt gleich ran.
Oben links, oben links ist irgendwas.
Oben links an den zwei Felsen.
Aber die haben es schon gewusst, ey.
Ich wurde verzückt.
Die haben es gewusst. Ich hab Shatter.
Alter, die wollen es wissen.
Die, die wollen mich.
Wo sind denn unsere Leute?
Da fuck. Sind alle tot, oder was?
Also ich bin hinten verrückt.
Okay, wir warten
jetzt mal, bis alle da sind.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich machen soll.
Links ist eine Mercy im Gang.
Okay, go, go.
Liegen alle?
Also, es ist schlimm
gerade. Es geht hier nichts
vorwärts.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Komm, go, go. Fickt euch.
So, bam.
Durchgehämmert.
Die pushen schon. Ich geh mal mit.
Nice. Oh, das war zu hoch.
Ich push mit, sonst viel zu langsam.
Ich lauf nicht zurück.
Ich hör oben links, McCree.
Da ist immer noch ein McCree
hier oben drinne, glaube ich.
Ja, da ist er.
Haha, McCree.
Nope. Gleich Shatter.
Unten links ist eine Widow.
Unten links? Du meinst im Haus drinne?
Ach, ne. Ah, da ist einer. Unten eine Widow.
Pass auf, zu dir kommt eine D.Va.
Unten Winston.
Haben wir ihn fest.
Gut.
Wir haben beide ungefähr den gleichen SR-Kader.
Wir haben uns ja auch komplett duo-queued jetzt.
Guck mal, die fassen den ganzen Dach.
Lasst euch nicht snipen von der.
Die ist down. Kriegt ihr den tot?
Halt so, WTF.
So.
Pushen, pushen, pushen.
Ihr Beste.
Ich liege.
Rechts Widow und links beide Supports.
Ist schon verloren.
Aber wir haben noch 1,40.
Das passt.
Es sind schon zwei down von uns.
Unsere Mercy ist auch tot.
Kaum Heal.
Kannst du pushen?
Ja.
Ey, das gibt es nicht.
Da geht mir so auf den Sack der Reinhardt.
Jetzt Bodykampen.
Ah.
Nein, Mann.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Okay, pushe, pushe, pushe.
Reno.
Da, fuck.
Klasse.
Was ist denn hier los?
Na, endlich, ey.
Das war eine schwere Geburt.
Hast du auch das Gefühl immer,
es läuft eigentlich richtig gut.
Bam, bam, Leute fallen hin.
Und auf einmal ist irgendwie nichts da.
Mhm.
Von einem Moment auf den anderen.
Ja.
Ja, genau. Von einem Moment auf den anderen.
So irgendwie bam, bam, bam.
Gegner tot, zack, pushen.
Moment. Team, hallo?
Ich werde irgendwann noch
Main-Tank-Main.
Wolltest du was tippen?
Bedeutet ein immer wieder abstürzender Mem-Test,
dass der Arbeitsspeicher defekt ist?
Fragt der Zwanzer.
Das deutet darauf hin.
Normalerweise stürzt der Mem-Test nicht ab,
sondern sagt, was Sache ist.
Aber wenn der Mem-Test schon abstürzt.
Ähm.
Also wenn der Mem-Test schon abstürzt.
Wenn er sogar bootet.
Also wenn er bootet, beginnt und abstürzt.
Vielleicht hast du auch woanders ein Problem.
Können wir contesten, weil ich hasse das immer.
Ja, können wir machen.
Man ist hier an der Ecke.
Hier.
Das ist immer das Problem.
Wenn der Shield down ist, dann droppt irgendwann mal keiner mehr.
Oh.
Da, fuck. Was war das?
Okay, wir müssen jetzt
ein bisschen, links ist der Junkrat.
Ja, bisschen hoch.
Monkey.
Reaper hat geschifftet.
Kriegen wir das? Der Junkrat, Junkrat, Junkrat.
Oben drauf.
Kriegen wir das mal.
Harambe fast down.
Ich krieg, ich krieg nicht tot.
Aber wir sollten hinter der Ecke bleiben.
Sollten jetzt nicht weiter vor.
Der Monkey will sterben.
Gib ihm.
Über uns, über uns rechts ist irgendwas.
Der Hanzo.
Hanzo.
Oben rechts.
Nice.
Nein, verfehlt.
Achtung, Reaper um.
Der Reaper flankt links.
Der Reaper flankt, glaub ich, links.
Achtung.
Okay, wir müssen zurück.
Der hat Earthshatter.
Was?
Der hat das Schild nicht oben gehabt.
Chat, habt ihr's gesehen? Der hat das Schild nicht oben gehabt.
Die nutzen gerade alles.
Das sind wir jetzt schon am besten, oder?
Wir haben TP.
Wir können den Fall gewinnen.
Gewinnen.
Also ich kann's, ich schaff's nicht, Deutsch oder Englisch zu reden.
Nur noch so ein Zwischending.
Nice, Port.
Von denen haben wir uns hier noch mit der Mercy zusammen.
Rekt.
Rektangle.
Okay, Leute, Leute,
übertreibt's nicht, übertreibt's nicht.
Hehehehehe.
Voll reingerannt ist er.
Oh, die haben jetzt einen Low Talk.
Achtung.
Oh, oh, oh, die haben Schild Shredder ohne Ende.
Nein, wieso werd ich gehuckt?
Nice, Schild, hä?
Achtung, hinter dir.
Der bestimmt gleich Shredder, oder?
Ich auch wieder.
Okay.
Was war das?
Jetzt kommt der Shredder, pass auf.
Ich lass oben, ich lass oben, mach das Schild kaputt.
Na, brauchen wir nicht.
Der flankt rechts, hä?
Können auch wieder kommen.
Ja, der ist noch unten drinnen.
Der ist noch unten drinnen, der Reaper.
Der Shredder-Kleider-Typ.
Der guckt schon. Der guckt schon.
Der will baiten.
Achtung. Rekt.
Aber sowas von.
Schreckt.
Haha, total schreckt.
Der Trip ist supported, man.
Die Symmetra hat auch ganz gut gegrillt.
C9.
Das war klassischer C9.
Tja.
Keine Karte.
Auch nicht.
Muss ich mal Stats angucken kurz.
Reinhard-Stats begutachten.
Ja, kannst du ja mal kurz angucken.
Ja, mach mal.
Ich geh auch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Leute, ich spinne mal ganz kurz.
Afg-Klo.
Zwei, drei Minuten wieder da.
So.
Wieder am Start.
Warten, bis der Ajax wieder da ist.
Nein, Eiskäuter.
Wir haben aufgehört bei 13 zu 3.
Und da war ich
im Prinzip der gleiche Rang wie jetzt.
Wir haben quasi in der Aufwärmphase
zwei Matches verloren.
Zwei gewonnen.
Also, wir sind wieder genau da, wo wir gestern aufgehört haben.
Du hast nichts verpasst.
Ja, 21 Euro sind safe.
Puh.
Ich könnte den Stream eigentlich mal auf YouTube posten.
Mach ich mal.
Sind ein paar Mods da?
Sind Mods da?
Sibaro oder Patrick, Evolie.
Ist irgendeiner von den Mods da?
Bevor ich das auf YouTube poste, brauche ich auf jeden Fall Mods.
Haha.
Doch noch nicht heute, GM. Ist klar.
Einfach, wir machen jetzt einfach 10 Wins in Folge und dann GM.
Easy.
Und Eiskäuter, was habe ich dabei zu gewinnen?
Davon abgesehen, dass wir definitiv, garantiert
nicht auf Platin droppen werden.
Ich brauche das doch mal auf YouTube.
Community. Zack.
Ich bleibe mal in den Chat ein, solange wir warten.
Papa Messe fragt,
ich möchte bald meinen PC upgraden.
Wollte wissen, ob man mit einem i7
und einer 1050 Ti
oder einer 1060 so gut wie alle Games
zocken kann. Ja, kannst du.
Kannst du.
Kannst damit alle Games zocken.
Kannst damit zwar nicht alle Games
in 4K und guten Details zocken,
aber du kannst damit alle Games zocken.
Also wenn du bei Full HD bleibst,
dann ist das überhaupt kein Ding.
Bw dann doch. Bw.
Ich poste mal
den Stream auf YouTube.
Da gibt es ein bisschen mehr Leute.
Wir machen noch ein paar Runden, oder?
Ja, klar. Gut.
Also nicht, dass du sagst,
Clem legst off und bringt so nix, wenn ich den
aufposte.
Kennst du dieses Gefühl, wenn du so
leichtgeistig abwesend bist?
Ja. Permanent.
Naja, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Also ich hab das manchmal,
wenn du dich halt so komplett in bekannter
Umgebung bewegst, sag mal ganz simpel gesagt
so Wohnungen oder so, da fallen dir
manche Sachen einfach gar nicht auf, weil die sind halt
ganz normal, die sind halt immer an der Stelle und sonst was.
Und manchmal hast du so einen lichten Moment
und dann stellst du so fest so, Moment,
hat das Ding schon immer so diese Farbe gehabt?
Weißt du, aber sonst, aber
sonst immer so voll Scheuklappen auf
und nix mitkriegen.
Ich merk die Tage dann immer so beim Zocken,
ne. Keine Ahnung,
dann stimmt irgendwas nicht, das fühlt sich so komisch
an, so alles.
Ich hab das auch an manchen Tagen.
Also, du könntest jetzt
gar nicht direkt sagen, was genau ist,
aber es ist irgendwie, du kommst so ein bisschen benebelt vor, ne?
Genau.
Gestern war ja alles noch tiptop, da hab ich so
gemerkt so gegen Abend so, ja,
okay, jetzt wirst du langsam müde, jetzt musst du mal
aufhören. Mal heute,
keine Ahnung. Heute geht's direkt da weiter,
wo es gestern aufgehört hat mit müde sein.
So, posten wir das mal.
Oh, jetzt wird's
voll gleich. So,
easy, jetzt müssen wir den Leuten auch was zeigen, die jetzt
an den Start kommen.
Bist du ready?
Ja, ja.
Kyurino. So, ich hab irgendwas überlesen
im Chat gerade.
Wollt ihr das mit dem i7 mal besparen?
Vor allem passt alles.
Wie findest du eigentlich League of Legends?
Das sind nicht meins. Das einzige, was ich ein bisschen gespielt hab,
ist Heroes of the Storm und das
war irgendwie... Mobas sind einfach nicht
meins. Iax, wie sieht's bei dir aus?
Hast du großartig Mobas gespielt mal?
Irgendwann? Äh, League of Legends,
ja. LOL, okay.
Ja, 2008, 2007,
da, wo's quasi so rauskam.
Wollt ich grad sagen, da gab's ja noch keine Liga und nix.
Da gab's kein Tribunal,
das war mega toxisch.
Das
ist ja ewig her.
Schon ne Weile her.
Damals, ja.
Damals, als das VG schon 45
plus Damage noch
1650 gekostet hat.
Oder 1850.
Ich hab bei LOL so keine Ahnung, ich blick da gar nix.
Hey Max, kennst
du schon den Ready Player One
Trailer?
Nein. Was ist das?
Ready Player
One.
So irgendwie so abgespacedes Ding da.
Ready Player One
Comic Con Trailer.
Was ist das?
Hä?
Das ist ein Filmetrailer.
Muss man das gucken, oder was?
Ich putz hier nur 0-1.
Was ist das?
Masked Watch.
Ich glaub ein Trailer ist so ein Tracer
auch nur mit am Start gewesen.
Da werd ich mich nicht irren.
Momentan find ich Heroes of the Storm
auch unbalanced.
Aber ich spiel es nur noch ab und zu.
Das erste Jahr hab ich auch extrem gesuchtet.
Ja, alles Kräuter.
Ich kann halt gar nix dazu sagen.
Ich guck manchmal Follow Krabby.
Guck ich den Stream.
Aber der spielt ja auch nur so Hobbymäßig.
Er war zwar mal Pro, allerdings nie in Hots.
Aber ich mag den.
Ich guck die Streams gern von ihm.
Der ist immer so...
Das wirkt so...
So entspannt alles.
Oh nein, da hat mir Lucio weggecrapt.
Oh, ich muss wieder in Mercy.
Nein, nein, nein.
Was haben wir denn?
Justin...
Haben wir Mercy Main?
Wir haben Hanzo Main.
Max ist Mercy Main.
Ich frag ihn mal.
Oha.
Okay, aber jetzt ist Justin schon Second Support.
Auch gut, auch gut, nice.
Wollen wir nur noch einen richtigen Tank, ne?
Ich spiel mal ne Runde D.Va.
Jetzt haben wir ja genug Heal.
Tank overrated, she baited.
Wo ist die Pharah hin?
Was?
Wie die Anna einfach mal über die ganzen Dinger drüber gehüpft ist.
Pharah außen.
Wo?
Scheiß Säugengeruppel.
Pharah ist fast tot.
Ich hab sie.
Mercy auch fast tot.
Fuck, fuck.
Ich kann auch ein bisschen contesten.
Nein, ich kann nicht contesten.
Das ruckelt schon wieder.
Nice.
200 FPS, aber es ruckelt.
Puh.
Kannst ja nachher nochmal neu starten, ob es was bringt.
20er kann ich gleich fragen.
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
10%.
Fuck.
Lebt hier noch was?
Nein!
Ich wollte grad voll reinfahren.
Ich wollte grad voll reinfliegen und das Ding abfeuern.
Was ist dein Mainaccount?
Ich hab keinen Mainaccount in dem Sinne.
Ich hab zwei andere Accounts.
Da war ich Season 3.
Also Season 3 war höchst rating 3900.
Aber ich hab ein halbes Jahr oder so nicht mehr richtig gespielt.
Season 3 auch schon nicht mehr richtig.
Deswegen hab ich mir hier für Livesteam
einfach mal einen neuen Account gemacht.
Siegster, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Ich guck gleich in Chat.
Du wirst erstmal die Runde gewinnen.
Gengu!
Deflect!
Oh oh oh, ich muss weg!
Das war ein bisschen
overextended so.
Woran sterben wir eigentlich gerade?
Lass mir doch mal was übrig von dem Roadhog.
Du willst auch ein Stück Fleisch haben, ja?
Ne, ich will mein Auto wieder haben.
Dein Auto?
Pass auf, hier tracert sich noch der Tracer einen ab.
Der ist hier außen.
Ah, Tracer fast down.
Na super!
Top! Top!
Meisterhaftes Play!
Na gut, du hast schon was hitscan-mäßiges.
Wo ist er?
Ihr sagt, ich guck gleich Chat.
Defense Matrix aufladen.
Den hast du aber direkt da oben.
Der sieht kein Land mehr.
Der Roadhog geht links durch.
Der Fahrer ist linke Seite.
Wow.
Ich checke überhaupt nicht, was hier abgeht gerade.
Links war es, rechts war es, links war es.
Ja, was denn nur?
Gut. Oder auch nicht.
Komm raus, komm raus, komm raus.
Auto gleich wieder am Start.
Was ist One Trick? Jemand, der nur einen hält kann.
Easy Win.
Nichts wirklich gemacht die Runde, aber...
Gut, ist mir auch recht.
So, ich bleib mal drinnen.
Wie viele Punkte das jetzt gab für quasi
Wie viele Punkte das jetzt gab für quasi nichts gemacht.
Mann, ich muss auch mal wieder
Ich kann dir nur empfehlen, such dir noch jemand,
mit dem du spielst, weil allein ist das...
Man ist so am ausrasten.
Ich hab 8 Punkte oder so gekriegt.
Lol.
Ich hab doch gesagt...
Ich hab doch gesagt, ich hab die Runde nix gemacht im Endeffekt.
8 Punkte, jawoll.
Ich queue gleich mal weiter.
Außer ein bisschen Defense Matrix gedrückt.
Gut, aber heute Leute, ich mach mal Lootboxen auf.
Zumal eine.
Gucken.
Das nehmen wir.
Currency ist auch gut, können wir uns irgendwo
Skins kaufen.
Und Gold, Gold rein. Nicht Gold.
Echt? Ich hab 19 Punkte gekriegt?
Hab ich jetzt irgendwie...
Hab ich zu lang geplinzelt oder was?
Hab ich jetzt irgendwie... Hab ich zu lang geplinzelt oder was?
Ich hab 19 Punkte gekriegt, sagt der Chat.
Solange ich jetzt nicht getrollt werde gerade.
Komm, ich logg schon mal Tank ein,
dass keiner auf die Idee kommt, ich muss wieder Mercy spielen.
Haben wir denn einen Mercy-Spieler?
Wir haben Sombra-Main, Hanzo-Main, Mercy-Main.
Sub, Sub, Sub ist, Sub ist.
Ich überleg grade, ob ich mal auf Tank machen soll.
Ja, komm.
Oder ich mach D.Va, das ist einfach OP, das Vieh.
Ja, mach das. Das ist gut.
Jetzt wird gehämmert.
Macht wenigstens von Anfang an super Schaden und nicht erst,
wenn man Charged hat.
Iconwald. Jawoll.
Iconwald wird gespielt.
Welchen neuen Skin findest du am besten?
Ähm,
weiß nicht. Also, wir haben's uns ja nur
gestern mal kurz im Streben angeguckt.
Was war denn der bestes Skin?
Der Tokio-Hotel-Hanzo,
der war doch nicht schlecht.
Ich nehm mal den Tokio-Hotel-Hanzo.
Den Hipster-Hanzo.
We only three in voice.
Ja, ich weiß, dass ich nicht in voice...
Komm, dass er happy ist, ich geh mal in voice.
Bevor der Typ jetzt schon instant,
der instant-healed quasi am Start ist.
Ich hab die Lautstärke einfach aus.
Soll ich jetzt mitflanken bei dir?
Ne, vergiss es.
Ich geh jetzt in der Mitte raus.
Pusherino!
Ich will mal reindrücken.
Der ist fast tot, ja, ich bin auch gleich da.
Oh, knapp.
Oh no!
In your face.
Oh, unsere Mercy wurde nicht geshattert.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Leute, ihr macht das, ihr macht das.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Fünf Sekunden.
Man muss die Leute immer motivieren.
Ich brauch zwar 20 Sekunden, aber egal.
Damn, schön in den Hammer gerannt.
Gungo, Gongo, Bongo.
Wie auch immer man jetzt, wenn man cool ist,
in Overwatch Genji nennt.
Ich weiß nur, dass man Mercy jetzt Murky nennt.
Den Aporetthanzo.
Hat ne gewisse Ähnlichkeit, kann man nicht abstreiten.
Ich krieg keinen Shatter.
Ich bin Kack-Maintank.
Und ich spring auch noch in den Shatter rein.
So wie man es macht.
Kein Firestrike.
Mach weg, mach weg.
Ja, so läuft es.
Ich hab jetzt Shatter.
Huge Slam gibt es jetzt, Leute.
Gut, dass du deine Streams auf YouTube meldest.
Ja, sollte ich öfters machen.
Ich hab die letzten Tage fast jeden Tag gestreamt.
Ich hab mir gedacht, eigentlich könnten wir das auch mal auf YouTube posten.
Zumal YouTube jetzt ja dieses Twitter für Arme hat.
Huge Slam.
Huge Slam, Leute.
Shield vom Reinhardt fokussen und dann geht's ab.
Bam, alles liegt.
Nein! Wer hat denn die Zarya?
Wer hat die Zarya weggedingsed hier?
Ich weiß nicht.
Wo ist Murky?
Alter, das ging viel zu hoch.
Murky!
Oh, wie knapp, Mercy ist runter geflogen. Über dir, über dir jetzt.
Achtung, Achtung, Snipe!
Fuck.
Na jetzt aber! In your face!
Alter, leck mich am Arsch, ey.
Murky hat so eine OP Selfie.
Der kommt auch noch hinter mir.
Der Slam des Todes war das gerade.
Ne, sorry, der Charge des Todes.
Ja, Leute, es war Huge Snipe mit dem Firestrike gerade.
Was, wo?
Jetzt aber. Übelst gut.
Ich muss das mal reindrücken.
Es ist aber keiner am Payload.
Ja, die muss ja eh erst mal das Tor aufbrechen.
Gengu?
Oh, jebaited!
Jebaited!
Okay.
Ich geh gleich die Widow contesten.
Ja. Jebaited!
Hat er mich.
Reinhardt!
Kommt der?
Oh, ich bin gestunt.
Ich war zu sehr mit Hämmern beschäftigt.
Huge Shatter, Leute.
Huge, huge, huge, huge.
Mercy hat geultet.
Oh, down.
Aber ich hab nächsten Fight wieder.
Wieder Shatter.
Oh, ein xQc-Sub.
Das ist 10% besollt.
Moira, willst du da wirklich
als erster rein, ja?
Moira, ist das dein Plan jetzt?
Ich schmeiß mal rein.
Ja, nice. Hinterher.
Ging nix.
Ist ja aufregend, Shatter, ne?
Ich hab...
Ich werd heut sowas von gecharged.
Huge!
Ich bin übrigens down. Ich werd aber gerettzt, nice.
Fuck, fuck. Irgendeiner ist down.
Gut.
Da wurde durchgehämmert jetzt hier.
Ich liebe, wie du Reinhardt spielst.
So aggressiv.
In your face.
Wenn man einen ordentlichen Off-Track-Partner dabei hat, geht das auch.
Aber das
kann man schon auch deutlich verbessern.
Beispielsweise, indem man mehr
Earth-Shatters blockt.
Das war ja mehr Glück als Verstand bei dem Letzten.
Aber das haben wir gut gemacht.
Die...
Die konnten ja nix machen.
Das war ja wirklich... So musst du es aber auch spielen.
Du musst denen in der Fresse stehen, dass die gar keine Zeit haben,
großartig was zu machen.
Ich überleg grad, D.Va... Ja, komm, ich pass auf.
Aber das geht?
Ey, die Gegner protecten überhaupt nix.
Also, da kann man mit D.Va schon
in your face reinfliegen und platt machen.
Das...
Mal gucken, wie es mit Saiya ist.
Magst Vanille oder
Schokoladen-Pudding? Schokoladen-Pudding.
Ey, gibt's... Steht Erdbeer zur Auswahl?
Dann wäre das vielleicht noch eine Überlegung.
So quasi, wenn man so
Joghurt-Mischungs-Zeug macht mit Erdbeer.
Das wäre eigentlich fast lieber als Pudding.
Kannst du noch gut Lucio spielen?
Ich würde sagen, Lucio krieg ich immer noch am besten hin.
Ich bin aber gezwungen,
Main-Tank und Mercy zu spielen,
diese Season irgendwie.
Also, Sonix.
Sonix.
Der Dritte.
Aber ich find's immer noch geil, der Ampourette-Hanzo.
Von der Frisur her hat das wirklich was.
Muss man sagen.
Max, bist du schon reich durch Bitcoin
oder ähnliches geworden? Nein.
Willst du mir ein paar Bitcoins
spenden?
Oh, jetzt wollen sie es wissen, die Gegner hier.
Gegners.
Schild weg.
Nein.
Ich bin da.
Aber Schild geht gleich kaputt.
Kommst du raus?
Ja.
Ach, ich muss auf Hook aufpassen.
Ziemlich low.
Haben wir einen schönen Hit gekriegt, Trainer.
Schild weg.
Ich muss racken.
Oben, oben.
Mercy ist links, Trainer.
Und noch ein Genji.
Ich brauch Hilfe.
Nope.
Mercy, retz, please.
Retz mich, Mercy.
Ich leg direkt um die Ecke.
Ach, komm ey.
Wo sind...
Wo sind denn alle?
Schon verloren.
Ist gar keiner mehr da, kann das sein?
Nee, musst zurückkommen.
Versuch irgendwie rauszugehen.
Stop.
Ich hab versucht, am Schild nochmal vorbei zu shattern,
ob ich irgendwas krieg.
Mercy, Mercy, Mercy.
Ich hätte einen Shatter aufheben...
Oh, wobei, nice, nice, nice.
Da geht was, da geht was.
Äh, äh, äh...
Fickt euch.
Bisschen kann ich noch contesten.
Ja, das ist gut.
Die sind schon runter auf 1, 1,30.
Ne, fast noch nicht.
Mercy direkt.
Okay, nee, nee, jetzt gehen wir nicht mal drauf.
Zurück, zurück.
Lasst euch nicht snipen, Leute. Lasst euch nicht snipen.
Willst du oben oder unten Action machen?
Unten, unten, unten.
Ich bin schon dran.
Lass mal ein bisschen draufdrücken, ab geht's.
Ich brauch Heal.
Mercy ist down.
Links, links, links, Sniper, Sniper, Sniper, Sniper.
Oh, ich werd hier weggerückt.
Ich hab dich.
Ich hab dich auch.
Fuck, jetzt hätte ich meinen Schild nicht runter machen dürfen.
Aber wir haben den schön viel Ulz gezogen und viel Zeit.
Ja.
Dem einen oder dem kommt das drin.
Das ist dein christlicher Server, wie kommst du...
Oh, ist die wieder drauf.
Okay, Mist ist weg.
Ich jump jetzt rein, direkt, Paylord.
Hammered.
Hammer-Time.
Kannst du an die Payload vorgehen?
Ich bin schon wieder da.
Ich muss erst mal den Zen bashen.
Ich geh jetzt hinter dir dran.
Nein, ich bin gehuckt.
Fuck, scheiß Play.
Dummer Play.
Vielleicht krieg ich den Razz.
Oh, huge Razz.
Das war zu aggressiv gerade.
Nö, war doch easy.
Nein, war ein Shatter eben.
Das hast du nicht gesehen.
Das war einfach übelst...
Ich hab ein bisschen Spawn knallen hören, aber...
Achtung, Roadhog.
Ich hab ihn.
Roadhog, Roadhog.
Mitte noch.
Ich geh mal ein Stückchen zurück.
Wenn du nicht da bist.
Roadhog, Roadhog, vorne wieder.
Kommst du?
Komm gleich, Roadhog.
Ich hab auch gleich wieder.
Aber wir lassen ihn mal ein bisschen rauskommen.
Wo ist der Genji, wo ist der Genji?
Oben.
Vielleicht einfach in der Payload.
Hab ich was geschattert?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen, ich hab einfach mal durch den Payload durchgeschattert.
Mercy Battles.
Wie ist eigentlich der neue Hero?
Kaum gespielt, außer ein bisschen Quickplay.
Okay, ich warte jetzt bis Leute da sind.
Dann gehen wir drauf.
Okay.
Lass ihn nicht gucken.
Mercy, Mercy ist am Abgrund, fliegt die rum.
Am Rande des Abgrunds.
Das war, nice.
Voll in your face war das.
Nutz doch deinen Shift öfters.
Nee, Charge ist so eine zweischneidige Geschichte.
Charge kannst du gut verwenden,
wenn du, wenn du,
angenommen du willst weg,
möglichst schnell,
oder wenn du halt irgendwas sicher erwischen kannst.
Aber einfach mal YOLO Charge ist meistens die schlechteste Idee,
die man machen kann.
Wenn du dir,
wenn du dir irgendwelche Pro-Matches anguckst,
ich bin weit davon entfernt,
vor allem als Main-Tank,
siehste, der Charge von Reinhardt wird wirklich nur
in ganz speziellen Momenten eingesetzt.
Also dieses, da sind Gegner,
ich charge rein,
ist in der Regel, wirst du gehookt,
wirst du geflasht, du bist im Arsch.
Also gegen gescheite Gegner machst du da nix.
Vielleicht gibt's jetzt
ja Master.
Gucken wir mal.
Ach, der Twitch-Partner.
Mal gucken.
40 Punkte.
Rat mal, was ich bin.
Rank SR.
3999.
98.
Na toll.
Also das ist ja quasi Master.
3498.
Das ist 98, das ist über 5,
das kann man aufrunden.
Also ich bin quasi mathematisch gesehen Master.
Das ist ein richtiges Game.
Chat, hab ich das letzte
das letzte Game
hinzugefügt?
Also nicht das, wo wir gerade gespielt haben,
sondern das davor?
Ich queue, okay?
Gestern die Minus 50 von der Telekom,
sowas, so Fail.
Oh, wir haben ja wieder 18 Uhr.
Also Leute, wenn der
Stream demnächst abkackt,
liegt's an der Telekom, dann bin ich in ein paar Minuten wieder da.
Ich will,
nicht, dass ich Mercy spielen muss.
Haben wir irgendwas?
Haben wir ne Mercy-Main?
Kennst du Winston?
Nicht wirklich gut.
Also ich mein, ich kann Winston
reinspringen, lasern und
Bubble machen und wieder rausspringen.
Das krieg ich hin.
Aber so die richtig
krassen Winston-Plays, quasi
Boost-Jump und
Miele beim Aufkommen
und da gibt's ja, Winston hat ja
viel mehr Mechanics, als man ursprünglich so denkt.
Kann ich das meiste nicht.
Aber Distanz einschätzen kannst du, oder?
Du meinst, ob ich wohin hüpfen kann
oder wohin nicht?
Ja, so halbwegs.
Hast ja noch genug Zeit zum Üben.
Ich hab, ich hab
kaum Winston bisher gespielt, aber ich muss
so viel Tank spielen diese Season.
Wird mal Zeit. Probier mal, wenn's
gar nicht klappt,
können wir immer noch auf irgendwas Klassisches switchen.
Na ja, Pharah und Mercy sollte schon klappen.
Dann gehen wir in der Mitte raus.
Go, go Lucio. Nee.
Geht jetzt nicht. Wir haben, wir haben
Moira, Moira, Mercy.
Wir müssen jetzt leider
bisschen heranbeüben.
Deutschland ist so her in Sachen Internet. Ja, ich hab mich ja gestern
schon drüber aufgeregt.
Oh. Gehen wir Main?
Äh, wir müssen
rechts oben hinjumpen. Auf die Ana.
Siehst du sie? Ja, ja, ja.
Let's go. Ana ist fast down.
Ich bin auf dem Genji drauf.
Genji ist, Genji ist weg.
Ich bin fast, oh. Ana lebt halt immer noch.
Ich bin drauf auf, auf Ana.
Ana ist down.
Okay, Sire. Ich muss
ein Stück weg. Sire down.
Winston.
Nice.
Genji.
Quick Mass. Bashing.
Harambe play.
Ja, lass den Pharah jumpen.
Da ist was overextended. Hier der McCree.
Scheiße.
Shield, Shield. Steh, ey,
ist schon, ist schon tot.
Oh, oh, oh. Oh, das war overextended.
Das war zu viel.
Zurück in den Spawn.
Ja.
Fangen wir doch mal von vorne an.
Spawn dann raus, push ab, gleich Ulti.
Max schon Rainbow Six
probiert Competitive. Ich nicht.
Eax schon.
Und, tja, jetzt spielt er Overwatch.
Sagt alles.
Oh, Harambe.
Oh, ich würde nicht gerne
shielden. Das war,
aber die haben so viele Ultis rausgehauen.
Die haben richtig viele. Die haben eure
Ulti, Genji-Ulti,
Zarya-Ulti, die haben fast alles rausgehauen.
Ich hab jetzt...
Sag, wenn du gehst.
Ja, ja, push schon.
Ich hab die Zarya.
Ich werf die runter.
Deswegen kriegst du sie nicht.
Ne, ich hab sie nur hinterm Zaun.
Ich hab sie.
Links im McCree neben dir.
Nice.
Oh, es pusht keiner Payloader.
Lol.
Ich bin am Payload. Ich kann vorspringen,
dir ein Schild geben, wenn da was ist.
Ich versteh halt nicht, warum die Moira pusht.
Die macht's... Sie feedet halt.
Ulti.
Ich brauch hier... Harambe.
Rechts war was. Ich hab irgendwas von rechts.
Genji, Genji, Genji.
Genji slow. Fuck.
Genji kommt von hinten gleich.
Genji kommt gleich von hinten.
Nice. Aufgefressen.
Ich bin gleich bei dir.
Der Zank auf der Payload.
Ja. Nice.
Ist die Moira weg?
Ich hüpfe auf die Ana.
Ana ist fast tot.
Moira auch.
Nice, haben wir. Gengu.
Ich hab die Moira klar.
Ist abgehauen.
Lucio. Moira.
Wie sieht's bei euch aus? Lebt ihr noch?
Ne.
Ich schau ab. Ja, doch.
Äh, WTF? Nein. Ne.
Was nur? Ah! Ne, alle tot.
Ah, ich bin raus.
Warum haben wir den Fight nicht gewonnen?
Er ging fünf Stunden gefühlt.
Der ist auch schon wieder verloren.
Kommst du raus?
Ich versuch's ja.
Die chasen.
Oh.
Winston low. Puh.
Ich hab gleich wieder Ulti.
Ja, wir brauchen halt bessere DPS.
Die sind so inkonsistent.
Also den Fight hätten wir eins haben müssen.
Das ging ja fünf Minuten.
Ja, das ist ja ein Fischer.
Das Problem bei dem Punkt ist halt einfach, wenn du da stuckst,
der Spawn ist halt direkt daneben.
Du musst die halt einmal ordentlich wipen, dann bist du durch.
Ich bin übrigens noch nicht da.
Stunkel hinter euch.
Fast tot.
Okay, jetzt haben wir doch 50% Charge.
Oh Moira, was ist mit dir los?
Also unsere DPS sind sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Da fällt überhaupt nichts rum.
Ja, da geht nichts.
Der Genji hat jetzt auch schon seit drei Minuten dieselbe Ulti.
Ist halt fast schon Griefer, meinst du?
Ja.
Schankert, fast tot.
Was ist denn das?
Ich kann switchen.
Kannst du auch Reinhard machen?
Ja.
Ja, mach ich.
Dann haben wir vielleicht noch eine Chance.
Ja, hast du recht.
Über uns, hinter euch, hinter euch.
Ja, nice.
Ja, ist gelaufen.
Ich dachte, ich könnte mir noch ein bisschen Ult irgendwie ergattern.
Aber nee.
Aber da ist nichts umgefallen.
Gar nichts, ey.
Der Genji hat jetzt seit vier Minuten so eine Ulti nicht genutzt.
Das ist wirklich schon hart am Troll dran.
Ja, Mr. Santa, leider nicht genug.
Leider nicht genug.
Hätten das alle gemacht, hätten wir vielleicht gewonnen.
Ähm.
Ich guck mal.
Wobei, soll ich schon mal Tank picken,
dass keiner auf die Idee kommt, komische Comps zu machen?
Hatten wir,
wer waren die Mercy letzte Runde?
Oder nicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Der Dark Lio...
Was weiß ich was.
Der Dark Lyoko?
Ähm.
Nee, wir müssen Mercy spielen.
Och nee.
Soll ich ihm...
Ich schlag ihn mal vor.
Ja, das Setup geht so oder so nicht.
Da kannst du nicht...
No Mercy, no Win.
Aber das...
Zumindest haben wir einen Junkrat.
Das ist schon mal ein Hoffnungsschimmer.
Wirklich.
Besser als kein...
Ein Junkrat ist besser als kein Junkrat.
Ich seh schon kommen, alles was er tun wird,
ist Desire vollchargen und...
Äh.
M.Hanzo, was geht?
Also, Faire Mercy können wir schon mal mitrechnen.
Das ist scheiße.
Für mich.
Ich brauch irgendwas zum Hämmern.
Die haben Bastion, die haben Bastion.
Echt?
Das sieht ja sehr Bastion-stylig aus, gerade auf der Straße.
Ich hab's für ne halbe Sekunde gesehen.
Pharah in der Mitte und Winston unten.
Ja, ich hör hier auch nen Bastion irgendwo.
Die Pharah kommt bei mir reingeflogen, oben in die Mitte.
Ich droppe Punkt.
Lucio fast tot.
Nice, so nice, so nice, so.
Unten drinne ist noch was.
Okay.
Moin, Markus.
YouTube.
Ich möchte gern Siegerl und Upmaster, der Klassiker.
Ja, so ist das halt.
Kommen die rechts?
Ich hab irgendwas gehört.
Ne, Mitte, Mitte.
Oh, die gehen in die Mitte, Mitte, Mitte.
Ich droppe runter. Harambe fast tot.
Ich komm wieder hoch.
Also, bei mir ruckelt das so übel.
Kannste nach der Runde aber neu starten.
Das ging doch gestern auch.
Was ist da los?
Ja, gestern hatte ich ja auch schon wieder diesen komischen Rucklart, oder?
Ja.
Das ist wirklich für'n Arsch.
Meinst du, das liegt am Patch?
Ne, jetzt muss man Windows 10 legen.
Hat ja mit Windows 7 keine Probleme.
Und jetzt...
Uh, huge pick.
Leute, wir müssen da nicht unbedingt rein, ne?
Komm raus.
Verleite sich nicht dazu.
Ja, ich will eigentlich nur, dass die in Ruhe zurückgehen können.
Leute!
Come back.
Siehst du in der Mitte was? Ah, Pharah und Mercy in der Mitte.
Anna ist down.
Fuck.
Wir holen sowas dann unten.
Okay, ich...
Die hat mir sowas von in die Fresse geultet gerade.
Aber...
Hardcore in die Fresse geultet.
Huge.
Huge ult in die Fresse.
Ja klar, Markus.
Ich begrüße fast jeden, den ich sehe im Stream.
Wenn er reinkommt und was sagt.
Nuked.
Richtig nuked.
Ich hab gleich Shatter. Komm zurück. Go back.
Go back.
Fuck.
Die Pharah über uns.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Huge pick.
1% bis Shatter.
Haltung liegt auf dem Boden. Pass auf.
Nice.
Okay, ein Stückchen zurück.
Defense Shatter.
Achtung, ich werd geflasht.
Ich muss weg. Schild geht kaputt.
Ich hab geplockt.
Fuh. Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Aber wir haben gute Zeit...
rausgeholt. Also wir können da noch 1-2 mal
contesten. Easy.
Ich lese die Fragen im Chat gleich durch.
Ich hoffe, dass die nicht auf dem Halberung sind.
Die pushen ziemlich weit vor.
Pharah fast dran.
Kann Sony Payload gehen?
Sonst ist es vorbei.
Ja. Ich bin dran.
Schild fast kaputt.
Ich wurde so geultet.
Oh ne.
Mehr ging da nicht.
Da fällt's.
Wir haben alles gewonnen.
Ja.
Leute, das ist das, was ich meine.
Aktuell ohne Mercy zu spielen ist Selbstmord.
Ich bin gleich da.
Nice, nice pick.
Wir können das gleich contesten
an der Ecke hier.
Aber nicht so weit vor. Das reicht.
Das reicht. Müssen wir uns ja nicht
in den Spawn stellen.
Oh, schön Saria gefeedet.
Zurück.
Kein Charge mehr.
Pushen, pushen, pushen, pushen.
Ich muss Schild oben lassen.
Wo ist er denn?
Über mir.
Ach du, über uns, noch ne Pharah.
Ich muss da weg.
Schild geht kaputt.
Oh, die ist fast down.
Die hat noch eins. Ein Leben.
250.
Kann der mal auf ne Highground hochgehen, um die zu contesten?
Easy. Das wäre mega easy.
Nein, ich bleib unten.
Ich mach keinen Flank rein.
Das ist ein Reaper, wo bist du?
Ich wollte Flank rein hart machen.
Die haben kein Schild, kann das sein?
Oh, jetzt kommt der huge Shatter.
Oh nein, ich hab verkackt.
Schnupp.
Ich hab auch verkackt.
Ich hab mega verkackt.
Ich hab zwei Sachen verkackt.
Der Shatter war für den Arsch, weil kein Follow-Up
und mein Charge ging gegen die Wand.
Das war einfach mega kacke.
Also wenn der Junk jetzt noch delayed stirbt,
dann ist...
Ich sterb delayed wahrscheinlich.
Ich lebe noch.
Ich conteste.
Reaper, Reaper.
Nice, nice Picks.
Reaper hat gut Damage gefressen.
Geht sich jetzt heilen? Reaper könnte flanken,
ich weiß nicht genau.
Hammer time.
Achtung.
Jetzt mal lieber ein Stückchen zurück.
Wir müssen da auch nicht übertrieben
overextenden. So hier an der Ecke ist perfekt.
Das Sire hat Ulti wahrscheinlich, so aggro wie die ist.
Ja.
Die will bloß noch ein bisschen Charge.
Ich hab gleich Shatter.
Nehm mal lang.
Der Ulti, der Reaper.
Fuck.
Ich hab gleich Shatter, ich bleibe auf dem Reinhardt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir noch ein bisschen gestalled.
Overtime pushen. Äh.
Tracer? Tracer?
Tracer! C9!
Die...
Was?
Moment, haben wir nicht auch durchgepusht?
Ne.
Ach fuck, wir haben nicht durchgepusht.
C9!
Der Klassiker!
Ja, aber wie?
An uns lag es nicht.
Ich zieh mal raus.
RIP Master.
Ja, RIP Master.
Quasi Master und jetzt wieder Drop.
Kurz zwei Minuten noch.
Ja.
Erster Lost.
Sag.
Oh Mann.
Lala Ghul.
Ich hab das Video gesehen.
Shinyboy97.
Keine Ahnung, wie man da nicht contesten kann.
Von den Leuten, die jetzt über YouTube da sind.
Wollt ihr, dass ich in Zukunft auch die Streams poste?
Auf YouTube?
Community?
Ich meine, wenn es da jetzt schon dieses Twitter für Arme gibt.
Kriegen es vielleicht mehr Leute mit.
Aber ganz ehrlich.
So mal ein Tipp.
So für Ranks.
Egal welcher Rang ihr seid.
Spielt zu zweit.
Der Tilt Solo.
Macht euch fertig.
Und zu zweit kann man sich wenigstens so ein bisschen gut zureden.
So nach dem.
Ja, nee, an dir lag es nicht.
Nee, an dir lag es auch nicht.
Und vor allem ist man nicht permanent kurz vorm Deinstallieren.
Also zu zweit ist wirklich viel erträglicher.
Was, wenn man keine Freunde hat?
Ja.
Pech.
Dann geh.
Ich weiß wieder, dass er das komplett nicht ernst meint.
Aber was du machen kannst.
Also geh auf Discord.
Und frag, wer...
Wer am Start ist.
Findest du bestimmt auch ein paar Deutschsprachige.
Dann kann man in Ruhe zu zweit Ranked spielen.
Na gut.
Die Tracer hat jetzt die Auswahl zwischen verlieren oder kontesten und verlieren.
Also da gibts eigentlich gar keine...
Ähm.
Also kontesten und verlieren ist auf jeden Fall besser als verlieren.
Weil,
mit kontesten und verlieren hat man zumindest die Chance,
dass noch einer rankommt.
hatten. Ne, ich glaube, wir hatten, hatten wir einen Zen?
Wenn wir mit Zen gehabt hätten, hätte es sein können, dass der Zen
rein spawnt, noch Ulti macht und ran
fliegt an das Ding, also ran, ran, düst.
Aber, aber
ohne Contest hast du schon gleich verloren.
Ich hab's aber auch ein bisschen verkackt, muss man
sagen. Mein Shatter hat zwar 4, 5
Leute getroffen, Problem war, ich hab nicht
geguckt, ob Leute da waren, sprich also überhaupt
kein Follow-Up.
Und danach hab ich's
auch noch verpasst, einen Kill zu machen auf die Moira.
Also ich hätte einen sicheren Kill auf die Moira machen können,
wenn ich nicht gegen die Wand gecharged wäre.
Aber das war so richtig, so richtig
noob. Ich klick mal YouTube
Playlisten durch. Was gibt's denn da so?
Rock und Hardrock
Music Instrumental Compilation
for Work, Study, Reading.
Das klingt auch gut als Hintergrundmusik.
Diese ganzen
Musik-Compilations haben immer irgendwelche
hotten Grills drauf.
Ich glaub, das ist einfach, dass mehr Leute das anklicken.
Also quasi
Thumbnail Bait.
So, ich hab einige Sachen vorhin im Chat überlesen.
Ich guck jetzt nochmal drüber gerade.
Erstmal gucken, ob ich nicht irgendwelche
Donations oder so sonstige Dinger vergessen hab.
Nope. Okay, Chat.
Äh, was hab ich vergessen?
Max, meinst du auch, dass
Mercy aus dem Spiel entfernt werden soll?
Nein.
Der Hero mit dem losten Skill-Cap hat so einen großen
Impact. Das ist das eigentliche Problem.
Entfernen aus dem Spiel nicht, ordentlich
überarbeiten. Die Idee von Mercy
und das ganze Design von Mercy, also jetzt
mal hier so grafisch gesehen, find ich das
super. Äh, übrigens.
Ich glaub, laut Overwatch,
Story ist Mercy, was? 43
oder so? Oder 39?
Auf jeden Fall, ähm.
Wie kann man eigentlich
seinen Rücken so machen? Das frag ich mich immer, wenn ich mir
Mercy angucke. Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist doch nicht
gesund. Also entfernen aus dem
Spiel find ich nicht sinnvoll.
Ordentlich überarbeiten. Gibt ja,
gibt ja immer ganz
gute Vorschläge auch. Und ich red jetzt gar nicht mal nur von
Reddit oder so. Ich mein, Blizzard hat mittlerweile
die Pros im Haus.
Im Haus sitzen. Für die Overwatch.
Die sollen sich da einfach ein bisschen Feedback einholen.
Ähm.
Spiel mal wieder only in Wert Top 5. Nein.
So, wieder da jetzt.
Ich stopp.
Ich hab's vergessen.
Mach das mal. Ich muss grad mal Leute
bannen.
Ein. Hast du einen 144
Hertz Monitor oder sogar 240 Hertz?
144.
Ich hab ne BenQ.
Ähm. Ja, steht leider nicht
drauf. BenQ.
BenQ. Ähm.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Hardware.
Vielleicht steht da.
Monitor drauf, wenn wir Glück haben.
Im Chat. Ausrufezeichen Hardware.
Vielleicht steht da dabei.
250 FPS seems legit.
Ja.
Seems nicht nur legit.
Ist legit.
Max, denkst du, man könnte ein Battlefield
durch bestimmte Modi
oder ähnliches auch
competitive attraktiv machen? Vielleicht in Bad Company 3.
Könnte man bestimmt.
Ich denke nicht, dass Incursion so die richtige
Sache ist. Ich bin der Ansicht,
was ein schöner Competitive Modus
war, wo sich zeigen müsste, wie der sich
wirklich auch auf hohem Niveau spielt mit guten
Spielern, war Squad Rush. Squad Rush, ähm,
hatte, finde ich, Potenzial.
Das war so ein bisschen wie Demolition.
Bloß halt Battlefield-Style. Ich finde,
Squad Rush wäre der optimale
Competitive-Modus, wenn man einen der Modi
nehmen müsste, die es schon gegeben hat.
Ähm.
Übrigens, Leute, es ist 18.24 Uhr
und der Stream ist noch nicht abgekackt.
Vielleicht schafft's die Telekom heute ja mal
einen Tag ohne DSL-Synchronisierungsprobleme.
Ich glaub,
ich glaub, jetzt sonst hab ich nix mehr übersehen, oder?
Also, wenn ich, wenn ich was übersehen hab,
schreibt's einfach noch mal.
So, wieder da.
Windows-Update.
Musstest du machen?
Jupp.
Feels good, man.
Jetzt ist alles besser.
Ja, ich freu mich natürlich immer, wenn, wenn du
ein Betriebssystem drauf hast, was jeden
Scheiß im Hintergrund macht und dein
Performance so mehr abkühlt.
Dann statt zu neu muss erst mal fünf Stunden warten.
Hast du, hast du dieses Game, Game-Mode?
Und, und, und geschätzt ausgeschaltet?
Also, gibt's ja gar nix zum Ausschalten.
Doch, du kannst in den, du kannst in der Option, kannst du, ähm,
Game-DVR und so ausschalten.
Ja, das ist ja aus.
Hast du aus? Also, überall.
Aber diesen Spielmodus, da, ich würd's am liebsten
deinstallieren, so, weißt du?
Ja, das geht nicht. Das funktioniert nicht.
Unnötigste Scheiße, was da von Microsoft kommt.
Vor allem, ich versteh's halt nicht,
warum die da so ihr eigenes Capture-Programm
äh, ausbringen wollen.
Wozu man das braucht, versteh ich auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich.
Keine Ahnung.
AMD und Nvidia haben das schon, das ist super geregelt,
das, das ist perfekt.
Also, den, den Sinn, auf der Xbox versteh ich's ja,
da gibt's den anderen Krempel nicht.
Aber unter Windows, und vor allem, dass das auch so tief
ins System integriert sein muss, das, das versteh ich auch nicht.
Soll ich queuen?
Jupp.
Solche Sachen regen mich halt auf, weißt du.
Ah, das versteh ich auch nicht.
Die hauen das eh raus, so, das ist dann einfach da,
wie der Windows Store, und kein Mensch braucht's.
Und vor allem ist das auch nur,
das ist doch richtig beschissen umgesetzt.
Ich hab's nie verwendet.
Oh, wir haben direkt ein Game.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir den Kami jetzt mal kriegen.
Es wär doch mal was.
Nope.
Ja, dich müssten wir erst mal Master tragen hier.
Ja.
Haben wir, haben wir hier Mercy-Mains?
Weidunno.
Dass wir das letzte verloren haben, das letzte Game,
das war so fail, wieder.
Wir haben die super gestallt am ersten Punkt, alles,
und dann, war...
Keine Ahnung.
Kacke angesagt.
Genau.
Klar, ich mein, ich nehm mich nicht aus,
ich hab's einmal auch richtig verkackt,
mit gegen die Wand gechargt und Shatter,
aber es liegt bei sowas ja nicht immer nur an einem,
also an einem Spieler,
das ist ja meistens eine Kombination aus mehreren.
Klar, es gibt Plays, wo man's komplett verkackt hat
und die Runde dadurch verliert,
aber wenn die Gegner so durchpushen
und dann mit so einer Zeit auch noch,
obwohl man den ersten Punkt gut gehalten hat,
stimmt meistens insgesamt was nicht.
Ist die Musik zu laut oder passt so?
Ich glaub, diese Musik,
ich mach die, mach die Musik mal n' Ticken leiser.
Hello.
Greetings.
Deutscher Hammer.
Wäre cool, Max, wenn du mal ein Video machst
zu .NET Core und Kotlin.
Nein.
Zu Kotlin mach ich nix.
Alles Java-basierte mach ich nicht.
Nice pick.
Ich, ich, sieh's nicht,
Hansu haben sie.
Nee, wir haben Hansu.
Nee, haben sie nicht.
Genji Tracer.
Die haben Plink Action.
Die haben Plink Action am Start.
Nein.
Oh, der Winst ist oben extrem.
Das fuck.
Schatten.
Beziehungsweise der Hansu hat einen.
Der wird gerätzt, die werden gerätzt.
Wir müssen zurück, wir müssen zurück.
Der Lucio, nice.
Mercy, die Mercy ist rechts.
Mercy ist rechts drinnen noch
und mit dem McCree.
Die pushen wir jetzt.
Rektorino.
Der Lucio.
Lucio hat auf den Sack gekriegt.
Ich krieg's einfach nicht geschissen manchmal.
Achtung, Hansu.
Ich hab geschissen, ja.
Der McCree flasht mich gleich wieder.
Können wir nochmal pushen?
Ja, ja.
Eindrücken, jetzt.
Ich bin geflasht.
Lucio hat nicht mal viel.
Nice.
Wo ist die Mercy?
Oben irgendwo.
Der Hansu, was ist mit dem los?
Ab geht's.
Zack, fair.
Nicht für den Gegner.
Nee, ist das nicht fair.
Ich hab gleich Shatter.
Jetzt Shatter am Start.
Weckt.
Oh.
Wir ziehneien gerade.
Onsport, onsport, onsport.
Oh, so geil, Lucio.
Jetzt wieder vor.
Der hat Shatter. Der hat noch nicht geshattert.
Hammer time.
Weg gehämmert.
Moin, little Samsung.
Dein Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Von YouTube, von Twitter.
Kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Ah, jetzt müssen wir früher Firestriken sollen.
Ich hab in 30 wieder Shatter.
Hä? Lucio onspot?
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Der rein hat er, Lucio. Da müssen wir aufpassen.
Oder hat er geshattert?
Ich hab's nicht mitgekriegt.
Der hat mich.
Hat nicht?
Die haben Welk an.
Also der rein traut sich nicht.
Oh!
Ich...
Werde dort wirklich vor jedem Scheiß gechargert.
Obwohl es eigentlich sicherer Tod war für den Reinhardt.
Ich hab Shatter, wenn ich wieder da bin.
Nein!
Ich glaub, du bist zu spät, oder?
Fuck.
Haben wir einen TP?
Jetzt ja.
TP ist da.
Ich geh wieder zurück.
Jut, Shatter.
Was?!
Noooo!
Was ist das denn?
Leute, das habt ihr nicht gesehen.
Das habt ihr nicht gesehen.
Oh, nein!
Ich hab gedacht, ich bin schon runtergesprungen.
Oh!
Fail!
Hahaha!
Leute, wenn ihr das sehen könnt, ich hab jetzt übelst roten Kopf, weil...
Massive Shatter!
Oh Gott!
Wenn das doch der alte Shatter gewesen wäre, wäre er runtergegangen.
Ja.
Fail!
Das war so schlecht!
Oh, Mann!
Egal.
Jetzt halten.
70 Prozent.
Wo ist der Genji?
Oh!
Kann man die pushen?
Ja.
Ich dachte, ich dachte die recalled jetzt...
Fast.
Fast, fast.
Beinah.
Nice!
Und wieder zurück.
Hoooo!
Ja, das wird geklippt, Leute.
So eine Scheiße klippet ihr.
Was?
War ja klar!
Ich hab gleich Shatter wieder.
Ich hab gleich Shatter...
Hind Нde gleich wieder da.
Jetzt gibts huge Shatter.
Irgendwo hüpft hier noch eine Tracer rum.
Die haben fast alle ULTs.
alle Olds. Ganz hinter Schrill.
Wow.
Echt?
Hello.
Huge Shatter, Leute. Huge.
Können wir ja gleich wieder auspushen.
Ja.
Jetzt noch ein bisschen aufpassen.
Der McCree. McCree hat immer viel.
Okay, wir sollten es mal nicht übertreiben.
Oh, wie knapp.
Wie teuer war dein PC?
Äh, guck mal, ähm,
was war es? Ausrufezeichen PC,
Ausrufezeichen Hardware.
Oder guck mal unter dem YouTube-Video, wo ich das vorgestellt habe.
Da ist ein Geilzeitslink. Da siehst du, was es gekostet hat.
Wobei die Grafikkarte
wird, glaube ich, nicht mit angezeigt gerade.
Fuck.
Okay, wir sollten jetzt ein Stückchen zurück.
Wir sollten mal ein Stückchen zurück.
Ist ja nicht egal.
Fuck, Mann.
Kriege ich ein Rest?
Ich habe einen Shatter, ich habe einen Shatter.
Nein.
Wieso haben wir jetzt wieder keinen Rest gekriegt?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich bin gleich da.
Gleich huge, huge, huge.
Big Slam, Big Slam.
Was?
Was war das wieder für eine Scheiße?
Die hätte ich alle gehabt,
inklusive die Mercy.
Fuck, vielleicht beim May aus.
Besser im Protest.
Ich muss da, muss zu schnell hin.
Overtime, fuck, ey.
Ja, Standart.
Ey, der Shatter, was war das wieder?
Ich gehe rein, alle schön drin, bam.
Ich weiß nicht mal was. Wahrscheinlich mit McCree.
Was ist mit dem McCree-Stun?
Ich gehe mal...
Der Shatter hat einen Boden aufgerissen und es ist nichts passiert, oder?
Der hat geschrien, gehämmert und es war nichts.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, das war ein McCree-Stun.
Vermute ich mal.
Juhu.
Vermute mal, dass es ein McCree-Stun war.
Wo kann man sich am besten einen PC zusammenstellen lassen?
Das habe ich irgendwie verstanden.
Warum?
Hm.
Das Reinhardt hat jetzt wirklich durch diesen Ultireset, wenn du gestunt oder sonst was...
Das ist scheiße.
Der...
Der ist richtig kacke.
Der ist useless, bis zum Gehtnichtmehr geworden.
Das ist richtig kacke.
Aber mit Lucio ist auch...
Lucio hatte das Gleiche, ne?
Du springst ja hoch und wenn du auf die Erde aufkommst, zündet es erst.
Wenn du da irgendwie irgendwas abkriegst, geht es nicht raus und es ist auf Null.
Wo kann man sich am besten einen PC zusammenstellen lassen?
Bei Lucio würde ich das so verstehen, aber bei Reinhardt, ey, das ist...
Und dann so Geizhalts-Detailnummer raussuchen oder halt auf den üblichen Seiten sowas
wie Mindfactory, Alternate und solche Dinger.
Es ist so, als wäre der Held momentan nicht schlecht, aber nee.
Muss ja mit dem Ulti auch...
Wir haben keine Mercy.
Ich...
Ich picke mal Mercy, vielleicht switcht da ein anderer Typ.
Nö.
Will keiner.
Aber die Overtime war auch wieder krass, wie ewig das gedauert hat.
Mercy all lose.
Ja, ist so.
No Mercy, no win.
Ah, ich hab...
Ich hab die Runde schon verkackt, vor allem der erste Shatter, wo ich gedacht habe, dass
wir schon runtertroppen.
Oh, der Hoggy ist richtig low.
Schön.
Mercy links.
Der Reinhardt ist richtig low.
Massive low.
Die Tracer hat's ihm weggeschnappt.
Ich brauch Heal.
Rekt.
Ich guck mir gleich die Fragen im Chat an.
Geh hoch über die Plattform, die schwebenden.
Ja.
Dann warte ich kurz.
Warte eh kurz, bis diese Kack-Häuser gut sind.
Jetzt kannst du rein, jetzt kannst du rein.
Okay, go.
Ich geh.
Boah, hier ist ein Roadhog hier oben.
Ja, super.
Ja.
Nichts tun
zu dich.
Der EQ hier.
Oh Mann.
Wow.
Dass du, dass du hier abgelehrt kostet.
Ja gewiv来了.
Jetzt halt ohne Mercy, Deutsch, ne?
Big Slam.
Wir haben ne Mercy.
Der Roadhog vom Gegner hat halt mega schlechte Positioning.
Ist so richtig unterirdisch.
Ne, da gibt's kein Clip, Leute, ne?
Wie sieht es mit einem Video mit Solution aus?
Ja, den wollte ich eh noch fragen,
ob wir quasi jetzt hier, solange ich Urlaub hab,
mal was machen. Ich hab ihn aber nicht gefragt.
BF Competitive wäre am besten mit Fahrzeugen plus Infanterie.
8 vs. 8, 10 vs. 10.
Das Problem bei 8 vs. 8 oder 10 vs. 10 ist,
du musst erst mal alle Spieler zusammenkriegen.
Das ist bei 6 gegen 6 schon schwierig.
Und richtig gut spielst du halt nur im Team.
Und 8 vs. 8, 10 vs. 10,
das sind einfach zu viele Spieler.
Jetzt.
Jetzt werden sie gereckt.
Jetzt werden sie hardcore gereckt.
Tyranus ist auch gereckt.
Junk links.
Die haben Dings.
Ich push durch.
Ja.
Das ist.
Ey.
Ich wär halt so jebaited von den Reinhardt-Charges.
Das muss ich mich, da muss ich echt noch üben.
Dabei war es klar,
da steht in der Ecke,
war ich bis um die Ecke gekommen,
um mich zu chargen.
Was sonst?
Fail.
Sieht man halt meine jahrelange Main-Tank-Erfahrung.
Oh.
Ja, zurück in den Spawner-Westen.
Ich hab Sombra gehämmert.
Oh, nice.
Weiß nicht, was sie da gemacht hat,
ehrlich gesagt.
Aber sie war da.
Heal, please, heal, please, heal, please.
Der könnte, der könnte schon Shatter haben,
der hat viel gehämmert.
Gott, ey.
Wie ich heute gebadet werde von dem scheiß Reinhardt.
Nice, Trance, nice, Trance.
Äh, Zen bleibt bei den Spielern.
Also, das war jetzt How-To-Nord-Reinhardt gerade.
Jetzt haben sie aber immer richtig getryhardert,
hier die Gegner.
Gut, dass ihr mich doch gecarried habt,
jetzt diese Runde gerade.
Die letzte, das war zweimal Mega-Fail.
Ja, no happy heal.
Was?
Happy, no happy heal.
Das wär doch was.
Das wär ein geiler Name für ne Support-Main.
Siehste, alles nur durch Huge-Slam.
Na guck, die Gegner hatten keine Mercy,
deswegen haben sie verloren.
Ja, Fail.
Ist so.
Aber jetzt, komm.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt Master wieder.
Könntest du den In-Game-Sound nicht noch laut...
Doch, könnte ich.
Soll ich den In-Game-Sound lauter machen?
Ich dachte, das passt.
So, ich kann den noch ein bisschen lauter machen.
Wenn ihr wollt.
Ein bisschen kann ich noch lauter machen.
Ey, diese Profile aufzurufen,
ist ja unerträglich,
solange wie das rumleckt.
Du wirst mir mal sagen,
ob ich ein bisschen lauter machen soll.
95.
Null.
Gibt nix.
Echt, weil, hallo?
Wir haben viel mehr gewonnen als verloren.
Wie kann ich immer noch nicht Master sein?
Wenn diese Personal-SR endlich mal verschwindet.
Ich muss sagen, wir machen hier gerade Tests...
Master Go.
Ja.
Also Chat.
Jo.
Warte.
In-Game-Sound lauter oder nicht?
Ich brauchte jetzt nur einen Anruf, ich kann das lauter machen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Ich mach mal ein bisschen lauter.
Ich hab jetzt ein bisschen lauter gemacht.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt 5 Punkte in diesem Windows-Mixer lauter gemacht.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal gleich.
Oh, Junkertown.
Bastion Strats?
Ja, machen wir mal.
Was hättest du gerne? Orisa oder Reinhardt?
Reinhardt.
Bastion Strats.
Moment, wir haben keinen...
Die sollen das machen.
Das ist mir egal. Wir ziehen das jetzt durch.
Nein, was?
Alter, was ist das für eine Kampf?
Was ist das für eine Kampf?
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen jetzt hier Bastion Strats.
Oben raus.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die auf die glorreiche Idee kommen, jetzt hier unbedingt die Kombination aus Anna, Doomfist und Junkertown spielen zu müssen.
Die Attacke beginnt in 30 Sekunden.
Schaut euch nach.
Ich werde eine Lohre geben.
Das sind ja die Lohre-Master-Games.
So Leute, wie ist jetzt die Lautstärke?
Ist besser?
Eigentlich haben wir Genji.
Jetzt haben wir eine Moira, jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt gleich viel besser.
Passt so, okay, nice.
Lauf mal oben ganz raus auf dem Steg, ohne runter zu springen und bau dich auf.
Ich glaube, du guckst vorne raus.
Ich sehe nichts, weil da ein Hammer in meinem Gesicht ist.
Wieso? Besser?
Ja.
Okay, aufbauen.
Kannst du dich hinstellen?
Ja.
Okay.
Das wird so nix.
Ja, keine Protection.
Widow steht zwar oben, aber trifft nix.
Ich baue mich auf.
Ich versuche dir nicht, den Hammer ins Gesicht zu halten.
Schild ist weg, Schild ist gebrochen.
Bin dann.
Oh, fuck.
Da geht ja gar nichts hier, das ist wieder der Wahnsinn.
Null.
Wir können uns nicht der Dreisheit hinterher...
Oh, Leute, was ist das schon wieder hier?
Ich kriege schon wieder die Krise.
Was ist das wieder für ein Dreck?
Gleich um hier, ready?
Ich muss Schild drängen.
Ich weiß, er ist hinter dir.
Oh, fuck, bei dir.
Hinter uns, nennst du?
Ich heil mich dagegen.
Moment, was zum Teufel?
Warum habe ich den nicht getroffen?
Doch nicht groß genug für Hitbox.
Hätte ja mal einer mit draufschießen können.
Oder die anderen eine Heilung abdrücken.
Nee, das ist echt...
Du hast die Ulti, warte mal, lass, komm, wir machen das jetzt.
Easy, easy, man.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Aufbauen, aufbauen, aufbauen.
Oh, Gott, das ist wieder so ein Game, wo einfach alle verlieren wollen.
Ich komme runter, jetzt komme ich zu dir.
Huge Slam.
Ich sehe nichts wegen dem scheiß Schild da vorne.
Passiert da irgendwie was hier gerade?
Ne, ich kann nichts da machen.
Also, wenn wir das so verlieren, dann verlieren wir das.
Also, ich werde nicht für die Leute switchen.
Ne, ich sehe es auch nicht sein.
Wir haben so viel Mercy und Tank schon gespielt die letzten zwei Tage.
Einfach nur, weil das ist die Comp halbwegs passt.
Ja.
Zumal es ja auch nicht an unseren beiden Picks irgendwie hapert, dass das eine gute Comp
ist.
Ja, ne, bei DPS doch.
Das ist die...
Echt?
Äh, Leute, können wir gehen?
Was, das ist wieder für ein Scheiß, äh, ganz ehrlich.
Ja.
Da gibt's nix zu diskutieren, ne?
Äh, erstmal alles blocken hier.
Äh.
Ich ertrag diesen Dünnschiss nicht.
Alex.
Äh, nee, nee.
Atex O.W. kannst du machen.
Welchen denn?
Den, wo ich beim runterfallen...
Wo ich nicht runtergefallen bin und geshaddert hab oben?
Meinst du den?
Was wollen die da eigentlich?
Was?
Irgendwas ist getriggert.
Ja, die haben Bastion drauf.
Und siehe da, es funktioniert.
Jupp.
Was?
Ich geh mal ran.
Ich hab nen Pick.
Ach, das war nix reingerannt.
Aber was für ein Arsch, ey.
Jetzt spielen sie was, die...
Das Team war zum Losen verurteilt mit 4 DPS.
Vielleicht weiter, oder?
Willst du ne Runde...
Warte kurz, ich will...
Ich hämmere schon Cancel.
So, gut.
Ist gecancelt.
Äh, ich futter nebenbei ein bisschen was.
Jojo.
Ich geh mal kurz 2 Minuten auf K, bis sie weg sind.
Ja.
Guck uns jetzt den Hanzo-Tokio-Hotel-Skin an.
Sieht echt so aus.
Oder der Ampere-Skin.
Was ist aus Lucio geworden?
Wieso soll er aus Lucio geworden sein?
Da ist er.
Da, hier, guck da.
Lucios spielt man zur Zeit recht wenig.
Äh, Moment, ich muss den Luz noch eintragen.
Bin wieder da. Können wir?
Äh...
Ach, das ging aber schnell.
Ja, klar.
Ich Q.
Oh man.
Ich freu mich schon auf die SR-Changes.
Wenn die Leute richtig schön massiv deranken, aber so richtig in den Abgrund...
Ich glaube, ich glaube das wird ne Weile dauern.
Ich glaube das wird ne Weile dauern.
Ja, es wird natürlich ne Weile dauern, aber...
Es wird was passieren. Bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Ich bin echt mal gespannt.
Außer es sind mittlerweile so viele Thrower und...
Äh...
One-Trick-Ponys auf den Rängen oben, dass...
Dass da keiner mehr Decayen kann.
Ich meine, dass die Leute jetzt überhaupt keinen Bock haben, ordentlich zu spielen.
Ist halt auch irgendwie lächerlich, ja.
Was war das eben?
Hast mit Bastion und Reinhardt schon mal quasi beste Voraussetzungen, dass du hier ordentlich pushen kannst.
Und dann machen wir die krasse Doomfist-Junkrat-Kombo und Ana heal.
Weißt du...
Ähm...
Ja, die Gegner haben es richtig gemacht. Easy peasy, durch.
Genau, genau.
Ich glaube, die haben es mit Orisa gemacht, aber ich meine, im Prinzip...
Das ist ja wurscht.
Am besten kannst du sogar Orisa und Reinhardt machen.
Das ist die wahre Prostrat.
Ähm...
95 Grad, hat irgendjemand geschrieben, hat sein CPU gehabt.
Das ist ein bisschen viel.
Ich finde es halt nur immer traurig, wenn du dann so Leute hast, die dann einfach nicht mitspielen wollen und sich denken, oh, ich bleibe auf meinem DPS.
Vor allem, das Geile ist, ja, ne?
Dann auch Flame.
Mhm.
Von denen, also ich habe von denen nicht gesehen, dass die einen Support gespielt haben.
Keinen Tank haben sie gekriegt.
Der Doomfist war der größte, war der beste, ja.
Ich muss mal kurz Chat, Chat lesen.
Ähm...
Hast du schon Hearthstone oder Yu-Gi-Oh! gespielt?
Ja, beides.
Yu-Gi-Oh! habe ich früher viel gespielt.
Ähm...
Hearthstone, ja klar.
Ich meine, jeder hat schon mal Hearthstone gespielt.
Aber das ist mir einfach zu random.
Man kann sagen, Kartenspiele sind random.
Ja, allein schon durch das Ziehen.
Aber bei Yu-Gi-Oh! ist es bei weitem nicht so random wie Hearthstone.
Oh, ich kann Lucio mal spielen, zur Abwechslung wieder.
Ja.
Lucio.
Endlich mal wieder.
Hat schon einer gefragt im Chat gerade.
Jetzt gibt es nice Lucio-Plays, Jungs.
Huge Lucio-Plays.
Warte mal, welche Map ist das?
Äh, das ist, ähm, Oasis?
Ja, mhm.
Also Dings mit diesem, außen rechts, also da, wo die Autos fahren.
Ja, dieser Steg da, oder?
Ja, das ist da, wo die Autos fahren, wo man, wenn man rechts rausgeht, also das ist eben mit dem Kreis in der Mitte.
Mit dem Häuschen in der Mitte und dem Jumppad.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee?
Du bist falsch.
Ist es nicht?
Das ist das mit dem Highground.
Kannst du mich speedboosten?
Ich will mal ein bisschen reaperen.
Ah, das ist, ach das.
Siehst, siehst du?
Voll, voll verpeilt.
Also immer schön speedboost geben und dann gucken wir mal.
Jo.
Ich hoffe, wir haben keine Pharah.
Spaßkiller.
Jetzt rein, speed.
Speed ist weg.
Das Speedboost ist weg.
Aber, gleich, gleich.
Soll ich?
Willste?
Jawoll, go.
What?
The fuck?
Prost Reds.
Aber das sollten wir haben.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ich hätte früher auf Heal switchen müssen.
Ich habe gedacht, komm, scheiß drauf, lass mal Speed an.
Aber, ups.
War verkehrt.
Gleich wieder da.
So, ist an.
Lass mal Richtung, Richtung Main gehen.
Unser Roadhog speedt.
Ich bin purple, ich bin purple.
Ja, ich bin purple.
Ich bin purple.
Kommst du mit?
Ja, ich geb dir Speed.
Speed jetzt.
Ja, ich hab nur den normalen.
Irgendwas ist hinter uns.
Lass mal zurück.
Ja, da ist noch ein Roadhog.
Bleib einfach mal bei mir dran.
Solange wir Speed haben, ist das...
Ui.
Kommst du mit?
Ich mach Speedboard.
Easy.
Versteck dich mal.
Wenn die dich sehen, dann ist es vorbei.
Ich glaub, die sind...
Jetzt Speed.
Direkt.
Die haben...
Haben die eine Pharah jetzt?
Ja.
Kommst du mit?
Ich bin schon da.
Machen wir nochmal.
15 Sekunden bis Boost.
Moin Max, was geht so?
Ja.
Auengeht.
Scheiße, komm.
Ach, komm.
Ich glaub, die kommen.
Speed, Speed.
Achtung, Achtung, Roadhog.
AD, Spam.
Aus hier, aus hier.
Fuuu.
Oh, ich bin raus.
Hier, weiter flanken.
Komm.
No.
Falsche Richtung.
Nein.
Keine Richtung.
Oh.
Done.
Die verreckten.
Das war schon richtig so.
Die werden alle verreckt sonst.
Easy win.
Wirst du in der Overwatch Open Division mitmachen?
Nein.
Du auch?
Ich vermute auch nicht, oder?
Nein.
Ist mir zu streißig, sechs Leute zu suchen, die dann...
Außerdem ist dann mehrere Stunden grind am Tag oder spätestens jeden zweiten Tag angesagt.
Hab ich grad Zeitführende.
Haben wir am Anfang gemacht.
Ja, vom Prinzip her könnte ich's machen, aber ich kenne gar nichts damit.
Entschuldigung.
Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, sechs Leute zu finden, die zusammenpassen.
Weißt du noch, wie schwierig das am Anfang gewesen ist?
Ja.
Da konnte der dann abends nicht und so.
Das war halt so.
RL halt.
RL, null.
Into Cal 17.
Arbeit ist doch nur halbstags.
Wer erzählt denn sowas?
Ich arbeite vier Tage Woche, aber nicht halbtags.
Kommst du mit?
Ja.
Speedbot am Start.
Wir gehen hinten rum.
Speedbot 1, 2 ist da.
Raus hier, raus, raus.
Komm wieder rein.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich fall runter.
Gleich.
Team ist gestorben.
Kommst du raus?
Nein.
Dachte mir vielleicht, klappt das noch.
Die haben sich jetzt drauf eingestellt.
Ganz gut mit ihrer Fahrer auch.
Und wir haben ja nichts gegen die Fahrer.
Der wieder da.
Direkt vor uns.
Speed, Speed.
Springstarts rein.
So ein geiler Held.
Und Blizzard verkackt.
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
Big Shack.
Komm hier, hier in die Ecke.
No.
Kannst du ein bisschen näher rankommen?
Weißt du, dass sie uns nicht sehen?
Ja, drück dich einfach in die Ecke rein.
Mehr geht nicht.
Achtung.
Nein.
Raus hier, raus.
Hier läuft, hier läuft.
Wieder rein.
Abmarsch.
Park.
Knockback.
Gehindert, ja.
Mercy links.
Fliegt weg.
Die können wir eigentlich einfach lassen, die Diva.
Kommst du zurück?
Ah, ich will warten, bis die Leute weg sind.
Kommst du?
Ja, ich muss ein bisschen Heal abgreifen noch,
da ich Ulti kriege.
Ich habe nur erst 90 Prozent.
Ja, kannst du heilen.
Viel Spaß.
95 Prozent.
Aber dass immer alle mitflinken müssen,
ich verstehe das nicht.
Kommst du rüber?
pre rewards
die
über die als Fahrer.
Ja,
aber die war fast tot.
Boote, ein guter fight und ein bisschen gestorben.
Und gut ist.
Was ist da?
Ja, go, go.
Links ist ein Mcree links ist ein Mcree.
Komm zurück.
Der kommt.
Ich glaube, das geht uns hinterher.
Makro von hinten.
Nicht so,
Moment, es ist keiner drauf zum Einnehmen.
Zinein.
Wahnsinn.
Kannst du uns... Ah, nevermind, den Reinhardt, den shredder ich nicht mehr.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, ich muss healen.
Speed.
Ah, hier ist der Wand!
Easy win!
Haha, der Chat flippt aus.
Reaper ganz sexual.
Ja, das war...
Ne.
Nein, war er doch nicht.
Ach doch, jetzt
unter mich noch.
Hahaha,
da siehst du mal, unorthodoxe
Taktiken.
Ich bleib mal drinnen, vielleicht
darf ich jetzt zu Master
hochranken, obwohl wir viel mehr Games gewonnen
haben als verloren.
Wahrscheinlich kriegst du jetzt zwei Punkte, weil du kaum mehr erhältst.
Ja, da siehst du mal, wie scheiße
und dämlich dieses
Dings hier
na, wie heißt's?
Performance-based Ranking ist.
Ist einfach lächerlich.
Total broken. Naja, komm.
Ah, 97
sind wir jetzt.
Ey, ich krieg Season High nach Season High,
obwohl wir auch verlieren zwischendurch.
Ist Wahnsinn, oder?
Komm, weiter jetzt. Alter.
Es ist ein echt
trauriges System, ohne Witz.
Das ist der Witz. Vor allem, wie will jetzt das System...
Genau, wie will das System jetzt
beurteilen, dass es schlecht war, dass wir deswegen
die Runde nicht uns vorangebracht
haben, weißt du? Total der Witz.
Das hätte ohne Speed nicht funktioniert.
Ich meine, das war jetzt nicht der
Genius-Play oder so,
da hinterher zu rennen mit Speed,
aber trotzdem, das hätte sonst nicht funktioniert.
Richtig.
Reaper und der Speed-Bus ist unspielbar.
Oder fast unspielbar.
Selbst wenn wir
die, wir haben am Anfang
in der Aufwärmphase, haben wir glaube ich
zwei Matches noch verloren. Selbst wenn wir
die jetzt noch dabei rechnen, stehen wir bei 6-4.
Und
wir sind niedriger als gestern.
Na, wobei.
Zumindest... Ach, für den Arsch.
Scheiß drauf. Jetzt einfach nochmal
easy win und gut ist.
Ich liebe es, Mercy zu fisten, Sam Fisher.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich davon halten soll.
Instant-Bun gleich.
Channel weg hier.
GM in 2K17.
Na, eher bei mir in 2018,
wenn das so weitergeht.
Nein, überhaupt.
Desmond schreibt, mir hat die Performance, das
Matchmaking in Halo 2 und 3 ganz gut gefallen.
Aber bei Modi wie TDM
ist das Bewerten wahrscheinlich auch nicht so schwer.
Ja. Bei TDM ist es glaube ich relativ
einfach zu bewerten, was
gelaufen ist und was nicht.
Aber hier?
Ja, vor allem in so Spielen wie Counter-Strike
oder sowas ist das ja mega easy.
Aber hier ist es wirklich schwer.
Das beste Beispiel
ist immer noch die alte Mercy.
Wenn du die alte Mercy hast, du hast...
Was jetzt? Error starting game.
Ja.
Ist abgebrochen.
Das Q nochmal.
Bei der alten Mercy hast du...
Hast du vielleicht einen krassen Rats
drinne gehabt. Und der das Game
gewonnen hat. Und sonst musstest du nichts machen,
weil dein Team dominant war, was auch immer.
Dafür sagt das Game
Nein.
Würdest du auch sagen,
für Blood ist Performance-based Unsinn?
Ich finde Performance-based überall Unsinn in Overwatch.
Machst du jetzt erstmal weiter
mit den Videos oder ist das Ausnahme?
Ich hab jetzt Urlaub, ich mach jetzt erstmal weiter.
Hast du eine Meinung zur Twitch-App vs. Discord?
Discord.
Was ist meine Meinung dazu?
Was ist das eigentlich für Gedudel da im Hintergrund?
Ah.
Hollywood.
Lass es nochmal machen.
Wir flanken hinter Gegner rein. Easy.
Nein.
Oh, what the fuck?
Nicht easy.
Ähm.
Probier es einfach mal.
Ich teleportiere mich hinter dir oder so.
Mal gucken.
Insofern er jetzt nicht Mei pickt.
Ich kann immer noch was anderes picken.
Wir brauchen was mit Schild.
Ich probier es mal mit Hanzo.
Komm.
Ich mach wieder den Main-Tank.
Komm, noch ein paar Failed Shatters.
Mal gucken.
Hörst du Metal? Quasi nur.
Außer on stream
hab ich hier manchmal ein bisschen Elektronik-Zeugs an.
Weil es halt entspannend ist so.
Und vor allem auch zum Zuhören.
Aber normalerweise privat hör ich eigentlich fast nur
alle möglichen
Metal-Geschichten.
So, jetzt wird gebasht. Komm.
Die Mei-Shots kommen jetzt.
Du kannst ja schön viel chargen, ne?
Ich kann chargen?
Meinst du, wenn die Mei irgendwas freest?
Ne, wenn die Wall da ist.
Go, go.
Ich wurde aus irgendwas auch immer gestunt gerade.
Weiß nicht, was das war.
Ich glaub die Mei-Wall.
Das hab ich nicht so
hundertprozentig verstanden.
Bist du da?
Ja, fast.
Oh, schöner Firestrike.
Reinhard, fast tot.
Liegen alle.
Vitiev!
Echt jetzt?
Ah, der McCree, Mann.
Nice.
Die Mei-Strikes funktionieren.
Null.
Hä, wofür war die Grav jetzt?
Schwarz, net so genau.
50% wieder.
Bis Old.
Das war dumm, der Firestrike.
Oh, schau, jemand hat einen Held gewechselt.
Das hat wieder geruckelt.
Ernsthaft, das ruckelt bei dir, wenn einer einen Held wechselt?
Ja.
Nice.
Äh, ist da rechts was geflogen, oben?
Das war ne Widow, glaub ich.
Oh, der Ghillie ist verloren.
Help, help, help, help!
Achtung bei dir oben.
Ich push. Kannst du mich das an?
Widow, Widow, am Ausgang.
Na, wenn's glaub mir.
Die rekt die halt voll.
Die werden richtig gerekt gerade.
Die Counterpicken mich.
Die Counterpicken nur mich.
Aber die größte Sorge ist halt die Mei und die Zarya.
Ich hab Silver-Damage.
Jetzt geht's ab. Gehämmert!
Hammer-Time!
Oh man, jetzt kommen sie mit der Ferne.
Harambe oben.
You will.
Wat?
Nee.
Dacht, Ghillie ist kaputt.
Nope, Reinhard, nope.
Das war ne, das war ne Runde Gold-Damage.
Null.
Einfach nur, einfach nur, einfach nur gehämmert.
Einfach nur, einfach nur gehämmert.
Die Strats, man.
Die Strats.
Six Strats.
Ähm.
Was Tom Laksa fragt.
Tut mir leid, wenn du die Frage vorhin schon mal beantwortet hast, aber trotzdem nochmal.
Wie sieht's mit dem Video mit Solution aus?
Ich hab ihn noch nicht gefragt.
Ich geh nicht davon aus, dass er sagt, äh, kein Bock.
So wie ich ihn kenne, ist er da dabei.
Aber ich hab ihn noch nicht gefragt.
Aber ich hab ja noch ganzen, ganzen Monat jetzt Urlaub.
Also, ist angestrebt.
Hast du auch mal Mass Effect Andromeda probiert?
Beziehungsweise, was hältst du davon?
Nein, hab ich nicht probiert.
Mass Effect hab ich eh nur den ersten Teil gespielt.
Soll auf Mei bleiben.
Äh, wer war denn vor...
Der, der Leox.
Leox, oder wie auch immer der heißt.
Das ging gut.
Machst du das U aus seinem Namen raus,
dann könnte es ähnlich sein.
Hm?
Von wem?
Vom Leox.
Der geht voll an mir vorbei, grad.
Ach, das U.
Ja, mach das U mal weg.
Leax!
Ja, fast, fast. Könnte es fast du sein.
Das ist der französische Eax.
Ich mein, Skipjack hat auch einen französischen.
Skipjack...
Skipjackwiss.
Da gibt's auch den französischen Eax.
Jeder hat seinen französischen Counterpart irgendwo.
Genau.
Stop on Fires schreibe ich mal einen Ticken früher.
Wollt ihr bitte wieder durchspielen?
Hanzo.
Hock.
Genji oben.
Two Hit.
Hanzo.
Okay, passt, passt, passt.
Ich komm mit, ich komm mit.
Kommst du raus?
Schild bricht gleich, muss aufladen.
Irgendwas auf den Punkt.
Hanzo ist in der Garage.
Ich bin vor ihm, er kann nix machen.
Und Zen Main.
Schild bricht, Schild bricht.
Pfuh.
Ja, ist klar, ey. Der neue Hook ist so für'n Arsch, Mann.
Mercy fast down.
Fuck.
Jawoll.
Zen im Café.
Weggehämmert. Ohne noch Silver Damage.
Zaurei.
Welche CPU hast du in 8700k?
Fails. Fire Strike.
Hanzo.
Hanzo. Hanzo. Hanzo. Hanzo.
Oh, jetzt wollen sie es wissen.
Jetzt wollen sie es wissen.
Zen hinter dir.
Frischt, frischt, frischt.
Slam. Big, big, big.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Help.
Hanzo Main.
Das ist ein Rektangulier.
Das ist auch erschreckend.
Allerdings sollte unsere Moira mal zurückkommen.
Ich weiß nicht, was der da macht, genau.
Okay, ich muss Schild laden.
Ich muss Schild laden.
Richtiges Rektangulier.
Oh, nee.
Hanzo.
Scatter.
Oh, oh.
Haha, lol.
Oh, fuck, ich bin in der Trap.
Ich kann nicht weiter vor.
Jetzt.
Was ist...
Was ist das für ein...
Das Ultra-Rektangulier gerade.
Achtung, Achtung, komm mal zurück.
Bei uns sind auch Leute tot.
Ich muss ranken.
Ich hab gerade den Zen ins Gesicht geschossen, hab keinen Damage gemacht.
Guck, guck, guck, scheiße, scheiße, scheiße.
Jetzt kommen die Mabels.
Fuck.
Overtime-Push, lol.
Oh, Mann.
Das war aber zu sehr
Aufer-Externe, ne?
Da sind zwei Leute schon gestorben, bevor der Push überhaupt angefangen hat.
Ja, ich hab Bucket-Verlust.
Puh.
Was? Was? Nee, nee, nicht so weit vor, Leute.
Lasst euch nicht bashen.
Links ist einer drinne, links.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wir gehen direkt Contest in vorne.
Oh, Mann, ist das ohne Lucio kacke.
Ich hab gleich wieder ult.
Oh, oh, ich brauch Heal, ich brauch Heal, ich brauch Heal.
Puh.
Tja.
Damage, null.
Ich schieß den Leuten ins Gesicht rein.
Viermal, ein Damage.
Ich hab Bucket-Verlust des Todes gerade.
Leute, lasst zurückfallen.
Mercy, komm her.
Ich hab einen Shatter.
Okay, go, geh mal.
Die haben kein Schild, da haben wir jetzt gut Shatter drauf.
Null.
Fuck, Mann.
Scheiß-Shatter.
Mal wegchargen.
Okay.
Ich hab gleich, ich hab wieder Shatter.
Der liegt.
Boah, was ein Gehämmer, ey.
32-5 Gehämmer.
Die Mei ist geil.
Die Mei ging ab.
Mei, Mei war WP-Smurfs.
Oh, Hanzo, Hanzo plays.
Was, ich hab doch nichts gemacht.
Sehen wir jetzt gleich.
Du hast dem Ryland den Kopf geschossen.
Das hat uns
den Arsch gerettet.
Ich war zu sehr mit Hammern beschäftigt,
anstatt zu shilden.
So, jetzt war's da, Leute.
Easy Win.
Easy Clap.
War's da.
Weiß nicht, hast du gar keine Probleme
mit Raketverlust momentan?
Gar nichts, gar nichts.
Nein.
Für mich ist das voll im Arsch.
Ich hab gerade den Zen gehookt,
Vollshot ins Gesicht, kein Damage.
Keine Registration, nix.
Ist der Wahnsinn.
Wir können auch Schluss machen
für heute, weil ich muss jetzt was futtern.
Und danach wollte ich
noch was aufnehmen für die nächsten Tage.
Wenn's bei dir eh nicht läuft,
wär das ja gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja gut, wenn du jetzt Finish machen willst,
dann ja, ich wär mir gerade recht.
Nee, dann machen wir jetzt Schluss.
So ein Gammel-Internet, das ist,
da taugt nix.
So, Leute, ist der Kami noch on?
Dann hosten wir den jetzt.
Jawoll. Der Kami wird jetzt gehostet.
Hat richtig viele Viewers. Der hat schon ein paar Hosts gekriegt hier.
Huge Hosts.
Leute, ich hoffe euch hat das Stream gefallen.
Ähm,
ich hoffe ihr seid auch das nächste Mal wieder mit dabei.
Was gibt's
sonst zum Schluss zu sagen?
Natürlich das übliche Like, Subscribe, Comment,
Donate, Follow, Twitter, Instagram,
Tumblr, Facebook, Snapchat, Patreon,
Myspace.
Äh, hab ich was vergessen?
Gut, davon
hab ich vielleicht die Hälfte davon gar nicht habe.
Wenn's euch gefallen hat, Follow wär nice. Ihr könnt bei mir auf YouTube
vorbeigucken. Ausrufezeichen E-A-X.
Könnt ihr bei E-A-X vorbeigucken. Und im Followern
streamt auch ab und zu Overwatch und
andere Sachen, ne? Ab und an mal.
Ab und zu.
Und...
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen.
Wir hosten jetzt Kami Katze.
Gucken ihr ein bisschen beim Abtilten zu.
Schauen wir mal.
Und, ja. Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Du musst noch ein Dings machen. Ein Keks-Rate.
Weil das die Leute, die dann zu Kami
rübergehen, ein Keks-Rate schreiben.
Ah, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Ich hab mal das Gameplay abgespeichert.
Ich guck's mir gleich nochmal an, ey.
Das ist nicht normal, was da grade abgeht.
Meine kurzen Games liefen besser.
7-2.
Guck mal, Kami noch ein bisschen beim Abtilten zu.
So. Boah, ich hab Hunger.
Woran liegt das bei dir?
Woran liegt das bei dir mit dem...
Mit Packet-Lost und so?
Ich hab nicht... Du hast ja vorhin gesehen
bei mir, als du das offen hattest, nichts.
Gar nichts. Und ich würd das auch merken.
Den Packet-Verlust merkst du ja eh schnell
in Overwatch. Auf einmal hast du ja keine
Hit-Bar, Kami oder sowas. Genau.
Gar nichts. Ich versteh das auch nicht.
Ich mein, du kannst ja bei mir mal jetzt
hier Stream nochmal durchgucken.
Dir wird ja auffallen, es ist halt...
Es geht alles. Geht alles rein.
Wobei du halt auch Telekom hast.
Das verwirrt mich so ein bisschen.